[Music]
are we live we're good okay
well guys welcome
um
to off the rails today
sponsored by Adam and Eve and hello
fresh thank you we love our sponsors so
much so so much
[Music]
hey guys can you not do that right now I
need to address
leaving my friendships
all right can you guys just wait till
I'm done talking about this
who's controlling that is that again
[Music]
Ian can you just wait until
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys
please stop just pause it because I want
to enjoy that but I can't because I need
to address the issue right now
guys stop what who's
Ian can you stop that or Zach turn off
the uh thank you God
you guys are so annoying like I'm trying
to do like sorry well it's just so
ridiculous because I have this thing I
need to talk about and I do want people
to watch that obviously I care about it
but it's just so ridiculous that you
guys play that I literally told you guys
before the show to wait
sorry until I talk about this thing bro
y'all you're not sorry dude all right
all right well you know what I'm trying
I'm trying to help I'm sorry I I thought
I was trying to help but
I I was wrong
I will talk about it later I don't want
to argue on air okay
so obviously
um yesterday me and Dan had quite we had
I mean about this I don't want to say
fight necessarily I mean we did have a
disagreement and tensions got a little
bit raised
and um
well
after the show we were arguing about I
said something about sending [ __ ] in a
box
which I thought was whatever Dan thought
it wasn't smart he didn't like it and we
were yelling at each other
I have the clip I'll show it to you guys
but
um
so after the show me and Dan continued
the discussion
and I just don't know why
I don't know why I dance sometimes
he just takes you too seriously it's
like dude it's not your ass on the line
it's mine just let me tell the jokes I
want you don't have to please me bro
well in dance defense I think he was
just concerned for the show I mean I'm
not trying why the [ __ ] would he lead
why would he quit if he was like you
know what I mean it doesn't make sense
like if he cares about the show why
would he quit right
just like it's like just let me take
responsibility
for my own [ __ ] jokes
and then
you don't have to worry about being a
stickler and then leaving
anyway we got in an argument and I was
like dude just let it go dude like just
let me be me you know
and the jokes made him uncomfortable and
he ultimately quit on the spot
uh which is really sad
obviously Dan has been a part of the
show for over five years he's a lot I'm
trying to get him back
I've been I've been reaching out to him
he hasn't been answering we need him
back I'm I'm not prepared for this in
any way shape or form yeah I think I've
already messed up like three times
yeah obviously
that's not going to be a permanent
situation for you baby
thank you thankfully
um I even get to talk about my stupid
[ __ ] hair yet because I gotta address
this damn thing
by the way my hair looks insane but okay
we'll talk about that later
so anyway I've been trying to get back
at Dan he's not taking my calls and
um honestly there's been stuff festering
for a while like I don't know the the
bombing that you know who one got
Dan I don't know he just takes this so
seriously he's like Ethan you have a big
influence you need to be careful with
what the [ __ ] you say I'm not
comfortable being part of a show that's
that's advocating for that and I'm like
dude just let me tell my jokes bro um
oh [ __ ] it sucks though because like on
one hand
he's so
I don't know man
I don't know what do you guys think I
don't know I had a line
I don't know what to say because it's
like on one hand it's like if you're not
comfortable with me being myself then
how are you going to work here right
I don't know what to say either because
I don't know if he's going to come back
I don't know
I don't know you pay my bills
if you don't come back
I want to know what you think
well are we gonna look for someone new
or like what do we have a plan with that
I don't know I haven't really thought
about it yet
I mean I think probably we need someone
else right
yeah
I think you should keep trying to get
him back I think so too
you know I've never seen him that mad
until like on the camera's cut on Friday
oh he was heated yeah
he hasn't even in our chat yes but how
am I gonna check like can I change for
him I just don't understand what he
wants like I'm trying to get him back
but ultimately where's he gonna go it's
gonna go down the same path as before
yeah
yeah
well I don't really know I'm gonna try
I'll keep trying and hopefully things
will work out
uh
but if he doesn't come back obviously
that's a huge loss for us and I'll try
to find
maybe I don't know
I don't know
Ian you want to be in charge
I'm cool
that's just a flat out now I'll give you
a raise I'm not touching this one man
was that a sound bite or Ian
wait was that all sound bites
the second one was a song
Ian this could be a big opportunity for
you bro
crickets nothing you won't even switch
to yourself
you won't even why wouldn't you switch
to yourself Ian
thank God bro okay you're fired you just
lost your candidacy
all right well whatever we gotta The
Show Must Go On so here's my curls
I went to Jeff's Barber Shop
and um
he wanted to
basically he wanted people were mad that
he didn't give me a good haircut
and uh don't blame him he wanted to give
me a good haircut and I said bro [ __ ] me
up as bad as you can
well he gave you what you wanted I said
listen
I've been growing out my hair for you
I'm growing my hair back people and he
said that this is the first time
somebody ever actually let him cut his
hair like this like usually the people
actually want like a decent haircut this
is the craziest one he said he's done so
I that's what people don't want to watch
me get a dope haircut I can do that
anywhere anytime I'm here to see my [ __ ]
get [ __ ] and by the way he lined me up
so good like look at those lines boy
like Moses clean as [ __ ] yeah look at
those fresh lines I've been trying to
cut my hair like this by myself for a
gag
and I've never really got us this good
like look how fresh that is bro
I like it actually I think it's nice
it's kind of avant-guard but it is kind
of a vibe
it's like that Meme of going to the
barber and saying [ __ ] me up fam that's
literally what I told him he said what
kind of haircut do you want I said [ __ ]
me I said Jeff just [ __ ] my [ __ ] up to
Vibe right now
it is kind of nice though dude it's kind
of luxurious my court My Curls look kind
of dope next to my ball dumb
you'll save money on shampoo too which
will be good
yeah actually I used my normal amount of
shampoo
and then um
it lathered up so much it was so nice
nice and my my hair actually feels
really soft right now here is a actually
my haircut was by Moses actually of uh
from the Torah the Old Testament there
yeah
so thank you to Moe's
yeah so um
that'll air is fun it was nice I'm glad
I buried the hatchet with Jeff and um
and uh the show was really good oh thank
you Gabriella she says losing weight the
same time as Ethan has been super
helpful you look great a lot you've lost
30 pounds 10 more to go
get it dude get after it girl
oh hey
what's up uh yeah no problem
what's up everyone sorry so sorry I'm
late
hey
hey dude sorry my dentist appointment
ran over I'm so sorry what were you
doing like at the dentist yeah yeah I
mean the appointment was at 9 00 a.m and
this dude was just lagging he didn't
even come into the room until like 11 30
is insane what were you getting like a
root canal or something yeah yeah and
you came here afterwards that's crazy
I'm dedicated to the show bro holy [ __ ]
I'm dedicated to the show so anyways
thanks for coming with me you need some
Tylenol or something oh I'm Juiced up
man I'm on so many painkillers right now
okay hell yeah boy you got any left
going spare by chance yeah yeah I'm in
pain after the show I got pain man
okay great well welcome back Dan we
missed you for the 10 minutes you were
gone everything cool everything going
good yeah we just started the show
without you because yeah all right
everything's great
so sorry I know my phone was like off
because I didn't charge it last night so
I
apologize I apologize well anyway we're
just talking about my new haircut yeah
it looks great
I went to Jeffy boys
Jeff's Barber Shop we did a fire ass I
think it'll be fun that's it I don't
know what else to say
a little bit of a uh
I'm getting a lot of Grinch
that are not grinched the mayor of
Whoville
definitely mayor of Whoville
yo hook me up he said what kind of
haircut you want I said yo hook me with
the mayor of Whoville son
yeah he's got to get rid of that
centerpiece though
it's [ __ ] up the whole vibe bro
or or what's the guy's name from
Zoolander magudo bogatu who got to
magato
uh zulanda
that Hansel so this one's more like it
this one's kind of almost exactly what I
have yeah it's pretty spot on because
it's his also oh no his is just parted
yeah
yeah but I could totally rock that
magodo
Mr magudo
I kind of like it I'm not even gonna
hate it like I kind of like it dude I
came home and everyone was shocked that
Theodore Theodore was about to cry when
he saw me
he's like when is it gonna grow back
Linda and a girl back that he did the
same thing when ELO dyed her hair
why is the title Dan quit the show
what the [ __ ] uh did you guys click bait
me quitting I have no idea you were gone
for you were late bro yeah I told you I
had a dentist appointment you weren't
coming back we had a fight yesterday on
screen I thought maybe you weren't
coming back that was all good after the
show though are you serious yeah no I
was just I was just trying to click bait
people you probably didn't do that
that serious though right like people
weren't buying it nah people thought oh
people knew it was a joke yeah okay good
is it working though I mean maybe it
works because yesterday okay in all
seriousness we did have a
people were you know me and Dan bicker
on on uh on screen all the time
My Yes Man over there some [ __ ] yes
we're like a no man
more like a no thank you sir that's my
mandate
yeah here I have a uh time stamp of us
arguing
although I guess I already did the bit
so
it doesn't really matter oh we don't
need to retread old ground yeah yeah
there were some funny memes about it
though maybe we could look at those well
people thought I mean
like you said we bit girl all the time
it was all good like literally 30
seconds later
people people
take the drama too far
cat says never do that again listen guys
we got you we got you guys do you really
bait these people we got you guys good
we [ __ ] did it
ain't nobody breaking this up right Dan
I don't know
psych [ __ ] hell no just don't be late
or I'll be next time will be Dan died on
then a car crash
every time Dan shows up late we'll just
clickbait that he died or quit Gaslight
the audience into thinking something
horrible man is in a vegetative state
it's not that far off from the ones
we've done
yeah no Dan is here to stay W Dan W Dan
Ethan you look like the lord of the
seventh circle of hell it does kind of
look like human horns finally my Jew
horns are visible
mm-hmm
it's a Vibe what can I say
um where does the memes goes that you
guys got collected
Olivia sent an album in the distance oh
let me resend it that's it
yeah there's some good memes here and
it's this one here let's take a look
so these popped up [ __ ] cracked me up
don't send him anything Dan crying and
then this [ __ ] up mutant this is Sam's
right that is Sam's yeah
what can you send him in the mail that's
that's illegal Dan
after the show after Ethan almost got
them canceled multiple times Jacob's
smoking again
it's me
that image is great man I wonder what
actually happened to him that day oh
it's just those two okay yeah
there it is Dan's here guys he's not
leaving
kidding me
what's Dan gonna go do
for real honestly honestly
get yelled at by uh
what's his name
the honeyboy
Shia LaBeouf yeah Shia LaBeouf oh
true right right that was my life prior
yo by the way guys there's a new Joker
brain out there
what do you think about this Zack
a far more terrifying rendition I have
to say
this [ __ ] scares me bro
just imagine your 12 year old waking up
no dude this face is lurched over you
I'm over it dude this guy just they
ruined it did James ruin it like
everything the Joker's cringe now yeah
you were here first he had to just
[ __ ] go and do that James the type of
Dude to dye his pubes green oh
you know what I mean
bleach him first bleach him and then
green you got to get the color on
yeah yeah
I mean if anyone's [ __ ] kids it's
Joker so
so I guess it's on point I'm just saying
it's just it's why that angle
why that [ __ ] because he's looking
down at a child
[Laughter]
sucks
this is the last image they see
yeah nasty bro nasty Jeffrey dahmers
um
here isn't take about
what is this about exercise oh God I
love these a new one came in that's so
good
more dating convos
this I don't know why I choose to
believe these are all real Dan this
one's real
not no because why has this oh these now
become my red flag detector for when
looking for men that's so true girl
it's so true girly it's such a sleigh
thanks
[Music]
but actually what's what's ironic about
these guys is that they hate me and now
they're not even getting girlfriends
because of me
right that's probably gonna make them
double down now they talk about how they
hate me and the ladies are avoiding them
because they know what's up check this
out he goes do you listen to podcasts
no that was her
kinda low why have you heard of the H3
podcast she's so smart
it legitimately such a smart flag
detector
he goes oh [ __ ] this might ruin my
chances but I hate H3 so much [ __ ] yes
she says why I have my reasons but yeah
even Beyond this podcast I hate Ethan
well for the most part why I hate him is
he said working out is for in cells and
losers
all the crazy [ __ ] I've said on this
podcast it's just incredible to me
laughs that a stupid joke about working
out which by the way I've been doing
every day okay
because you're an insult loser
that's the game it's just [ __ ]
incredible he goes working out for and
sell losers implying he can get girls
when he met Ela on Israeli sponsored
trip to Israel which is for the most
part meant to connect israeli-born
Jewish women
with Jewish men and then he goes
this is my favorite part I know that
probably sounds slightly anti-Semitic
laughs
dude this girl unlocks the perfect
Gateway into his heart and mind
she's like do you like H3
he's like no I hate Jews though
the Jews I know that sounds slightly
anti-semitic but that's how he met her
then he wants to talk [ __ ] about people
who just care about their health so I I
was trying to untangle that but I think
he what he's saying is that
I could never get a girl unless she was
like some Israeli Shield that was paid
to marry me or something correct that's
wild bro
it seems like this person knows a lot
about you though which I find
interesting
yeah but I would say yeah that's true
but a lot of people know that stuff
about me know
Fair yeah Fallen fan Lord that's like
yeah yeah like that's that's Fallen fan
knowledge
dude why I'm falling why are you like
this bro you never even said that about
working out no
how did it turn into working out as far
in cells and losers it was just a stupid
joke about how
if you tally up every hour working out
will it give you a longer life than not
working out you know it's kind of even a
fun
I refuse to
if I will never deny that that's not an
interesting thought
Megan Sullivan said can we finish the
intro now please oh
I think they did I think they did it was
good oh by the way it was really good
thank you thank you yeah that was a full
intro no it was fun it was good thank
you
uh Zach are you wearing a shirt that
says goat yeah well don't call him Zach
yeah I can't call him whenever I wear
this shirt I go by Lou yeah he's Lou
today and then when that when we're not
wearing that shirt we do not know Hulu
is yeah we completely and and why are
you so valued today I'm just Lou because
lose the goat dude yeah Lou I am Go Big
Lou so so Zach is not the God no Zach
Zach's cool but lose the goat okay and
so you can have Zach when I'm not
wearing this shirt and what makes Lou
the goat I just am the goat
you just are yeah did you see the shirt
that he's wearing yeah I it was it says
go right yeah you can call me Lou Lou
took over my Twitter account yeah you
know before gulp became greatest of all
time I used to whenever I heard goat I
would think of goat goat sea oh yeah
yeah yeah so
um so yeah you can refer to me as Lou
today okay I'm not gonna do that
but I'm the goat okay you can be the
goat okay I can't guarantee I'm gonna
remember to call you lulu big Louie
Louie confusing Zach to be fair well
it's only when I wear the shirt so yeah
you want to do it all the time this is
confusing can we just pick one name
please and stick with that
maybe if it said Lou the shirt said Lou
then yeah that would be that would be
make more sense Lou means goat so uh I'm
going bowling later so right you know
I'm the goat okay yeah Roger that
whatever you say there Louie boy yes
there you go
that's hard but thank you very much Lou
the goat ladies and gentlemen thank you
respect his nouns
uh yeah guys we're gonna do put Lovato
we're just covering some top of the show
business oh by the way Teddy fresh dude
this is a 2XL and I'm like this [ __ ]
does not fit me at all anymore
like look how big this is it is baggy
and I had to roll up the sleeve because
apparently my your arms shrunk too
strong
that's crazy how that works my dick
shrunk too I don't know it's crazy wow
everything's shrinking wait is it losing
weight isn't that supposed to get bigger
I lost 20 pounds but it was all in my
dick come on it just keeps getting
smaller and smaller
guys this uh
this uh
Polo sweatshirt
beautifully crafted this embroidery is
gorgeous fabric is lovely and it'll look
even better
on a size that fit me
but there it is
consider a gift for your loved one this
holiday season coming up here yeah
you know
can you believe it's going to be the
the holidays already coming around the
corner man that's crazy yes your flew by
I really did huh
good year though guys
yeah had a great year with you guys oh
thank you what year is it
uh 2022 almost 23. yeah but Bruce is
going to be a year old and February wow
damn that's crazy isn't it a little bit
he's a good kid that that Brucie
anyway moving on uh okay here's one that
we've been meaning to watch uh H3 crew
as 80s wrestlers actually Elie even
changed her WhatsApp profile
to the one that they made for her yeah
shout out to this here's the great memes
here is Dan looking like
Dan the Muscle Man's word love yep
it looks real Brian I love it too
here is me and Hildago
this one looks a little [ __ ] up it
says Ethan the wife guy you see the
titles at the top Ethan the white guy
and Ila the bad mama I'm not a wife guy
well it's just your wrestler Persona
that's a [ __ ] wrestling Persona well
they give you a few options here to
choose from Zach The Thrasher Lewis
shout out uh
Macho Man Ray
that's why you're Lou
what your last name's Lewis yeah that's
fine that makes sense but it's my Alter
Ego Lou yeah you're right yeah when I
put this shirt on like you know blue
steps out like my super hero outfit okay
blue yeah all righty oh Leah interesting
okay slay Lena the blue bolt wow I look
so much like my mom in there really
that's crazy
yeah you do
this is ela's new profile pic all right
Ela step on me mommy Clyde
this is love the lightning bolt this
one's crazy like I barely recognize it
me neither awesome
Olivia the red champ
that one looks super real
Ian okay
the vicious
mm-hmm he has a massive penis thoughts
on this Ian
uh it's great Zach nailed it with the
sound bite
was that a sound bite or he has a
massive penis do you have a massive pain
I mean why would you say that about
yourself a little bizarre didn't ask
um
Sam oh
okay Dark Storm
Dark Storm
a b now this is a this is my favorite
one this is the ab
ah the Cobra charmer what do we think
baby
I think they used an edited photo of me
because one [ __ ] guy is bigger than
the other like way bigger yeah
looks fine to me I don't know what
you're talking about
Gabe yes as Andre the Giant gave the
immortal this is everything to me
yes how you doing
dishes are like pretty high level of
photoshops aren't they cam
yeah I think it's ASAP but yeah oh it's
just a face app
I thought they might do some retouching
efforts Ethan pretty boy Klein yeah I
like that tiny hand
and then who the [ __ ] is this oh that's
ABC I can't even tell that this one I'll
take that one not as funny but I'll take
it but does that look like you or is
that oh I look more like the [ __ ] up
eye one well I saw you I had no offense
but I saw you more than that one than
this one yeah because you've been seeing
that [ __ ] photo everywhere
hmm
this is of course me and Zach five
finger boys there we go dude pull my
finger pull my finger sorry excuse me
this is his son the small head Viking
and uh this is Cam and love the greatest
tag team ever oh yeah
we look like we should not be allowed
near a school like that yeah sir
yeah it wouldn't be opposed to that
another cam in love I like this one
that's my this one's better yeah I don't
mind that one
oh this is good the leftover yeah it's
really good yo is his head really that
small like it looks like he got a tiny
head
it is very small man
and there it is the ultimate fupa slam
spectacular podcast lxix whatever that
number is
69
oh
vry think of it A Gifted kmr kmr five
good thing to be gifted
Sarah G think of it again
yeah yeah
by the way speaking of ninja we keep
having um back and forth with him
excuse me he mentioned us again on his
stream yesterday and things are just
heating up this friendship is blossoming
and um
things are moving fast and I like that
here's Ninja
have a great day man think of the 999c
appreciate it Johnny said please on the
History Podcast God nobody can beat him
nobody can touch his sub thank yous
such a legend dude Nobody Does it Like
Him Ian Slater I think of the 999 she
appreciate it Johnny said please on the
H3 podcast man yeah I know I'm gonna
respond soon to Ethan just been busy
thanks bro take your time flavor take
your time player your ninja you're busy
man dude
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is your home now
this is a safe place for new this is
where you belong like ninja will always
feel safe and loved here safe space
he's the only one by the way
for everyone else this is a war zone my
home
um
yo this is [ __ ] up you guys are gonna
be pissed off as me about this one
Markiplier we talked about milk applier
on the last episode
and somebody dug up this clip of him on
his [ __ ]
podcast by the way didn't he ever get
number one on he's number one on Spotify
oh he did he passed Rogan last I looked
to you I'm still behind Rogan yeah we we
were we did a slight goofing on Mark uh
the other was that a Monday yeah
because uh he said he'll start only fans
if people can spam his [ __ ] enough to
get him at the top of the podcast charts
I don't know that he succeeded which is
kind of embarrassing for him after he
like debased himself to such
degrading levels
not there
oh he's number one on Spotify number
nine on Apple that's it bro
by the way this list is such [ __ ] I
was looking at it Tulsi gabbard show
nobody's watching that [ __ ] are you
kidding me Rachel Maddow
are you [ __ ] kidding me am I right
nobody's listening to Tulsi gabbard
podcast
I mean he is somebody is but oh
from the policy stands the ones with the
little
Hawaiian flowers in their Twitter handle
you know the Yo Gabba gabbards yeah the
Tulsi tots yeah and Tulsi [ __ ] Jay
shetty's asses on here yo oh you did
this one shed it again we're gonna have
to get that guy in the show we have to
and I'm just gonna be like who the [ __ ]
are you bro I don't know anything about
you but you are the bane of my existence
I don't know if we're even on this one
on Spotify yeah I doubt it yeah you
because you have to actually go to the
surveys which is the real
um
that's where you really find out well 90
of our viewers are on YouTube you know
this is purely audio numbers it's
embarrassing to be on this list cringe
uh are we on this though I'm desperate
to find out now [ __ ] embarrassing look
at number 87 what the [ __ ] going on
there
why are we not on this list
it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] dude yeah I saw
that the funny tick tocks is a podcast
that has more views than us with a
minion or not a minion a [ __ ] Among
Us
Poltergeist dude I'm about to drop I'm
about to drop my dick pic I threatened
you all yet on Monday and I'm not even
on this list in the 100 you [ __ ] you're
about to see my prolapse anus hi I'm
dick tipps now get on there go to Best
Buy go to Apple wherever the [ __ ] you
have to do it and just stream this on
all of them pissed off
you Jay said he's number 15 bro
dude how Best Buy has a chart
I know but I'm just saying they have a
bunch of computers there everywhere yeah
you know what I mean just open it on all
the computers go to the phones too the
phones too yeah go to Apple yes Circuit
City are they still in business uh they
have not been for about 20 years
20 years really I think it's been like
closer let's do a liquidation sale for
Circuit City if the love Circuit City
that's my favorite spot I was always a
prize boy but fries is gone now too
fries is gone rip to the go rip to the
actual goat my dude fries is gone when
did that happen what are these things oh
you've never heard of fries no it's like
an electronic Superstore oh never
Circuit City was like
and all back in the day yep Fry's was a
regional though so I think only people
on the west coast know what fries is
Circus city was there's a threat no
there's a fries in the valley
I mean a little bit further east than
the valley
the western United States is where fries
were right because yeah anywhere in In
and Out Burgers there's a fries wait
when did fries that's how L.A you are
it's like off the coast
yeah I mean that's where the that's
where the Border ends and my fries was
uh
2021 I think yeah it just it just went
out of business very recently yeah but
if you go in one of those it's kind of
mystical like they have the biggest
[ __ ] buildings you've ever seen I'm
seeing people say it was in Texas
yeah I think I guess maybe just not all
the way oh price was in Georgia okay I
thought it was just like the Southwest
but maybe it was yeah but anyway guys
like listen
come on y'all please just get me on this
list I guess Fry's has gone circuit
City's gone Apple you can still go open
on all the phones
Best Buy's still open I don't know how
best guys they're sold in please is
there any other stores that people can
go
um here in La most of like the tobacco
shops um also do iPhone screen repairs
so maybe they have a bunch of uh you
know a little Bodega actually you break
you break
a bong Supply
I've been
yeah if you guys have any ideas if you
want to go have streaming parties at
Best Buy you want me to help collab uh
organize that just let me know because
when you get on this [ __ ] list [ __ ]
Tulsi gabbard bro why is she number
three she's not sponsored by Adam and
Eve
you she dreams of that yeah the only
person she's sponsored by is Vladimir
Putin am I right Dan
she's on the paper all Breaking dumb she
is Bro [ __ ] freaking lip Dart yeah so
anyway Mark so here show me the podcast
on uh
on iTunes the iTunes top chart
yeah let's see if you got there mark
dude literally said I'll show you my
dick and they couldn't even get his ass
to number one
l
thank you for the gifted
uh
thank you they J Phillip thanks for
gifted uh Joshua
dude
it's a gifted from uh and a happy
birthday shout out today
it's her 21st birthday Zach you know
what to do 21st
21 21 [ __ ] you
yeah so here's the plug uh the iTunes
one let's take a look here
he's number
let's see this is Spotify Apple all
podcast it just has all of them here
wait what this can't be right
number nine he's number nine on Apple
app wait why is Rachel Maddow number one
that doesn't make oh Joe Rogan's not on
it anymore
right that's right that's crazy okay
okay I see so Rachel Maddow has that
that doesn't make any sense nobody even
likes her
does that make sister sense I mean I
don't think that's true
I I don't I personally I don't I don't
know that likes Rachel Maddow well
there's
there's Howard Stern other people out
there not that many people I've met her
you met her during the election I'd want
to try lunchtime
there was an NAACP dinner with her my
dad were awarded the same night
oh but this is a long time ago I don't
know
yeah I think a lot of Boomers like
Rachel okay listen
Mark your ass has already dropped two
spots you couldn't even surpass Rachel
[ __ ] Mata presents
[Music]
sorry brother
are we on this though by the way
let's see
again this is streaming number so don't
feel bad guys we don't belong on this
list
we're too good for lists like these
we're so much more than this yo she's
got the top and bottom spots
save some spots for the for the rest of
us oh [ __ ]
yeah I don't see it so guys come on what
are we doing here anyway Mark failed
loser l
um oh
but here he is somebody dug this up I
guess because we were talking about him
this Puck has actually
is from June something like that this
past summer but he's talking about how
he muted me on Twitter it was in June
this year
what
why would you even cut that
you never know man there's a one in 12
chance you could use it
it's got the entire English dictionary
Jordan Peterson sound bites you can
create anything at this point
yo what's here love sent this I bet they
don't have these views but wait you got
to include our YouTube views too which
is usually like 20 million a month oh oh
yeah something like that these are the
ones I do so
I'd like to check them bro we're juicing
over our Tick Tock Instagram shorts [ __ ]
juicy boy
[Applause]
[ __ ] they got nothing on us anyway
here's Mark who started World War uh
three with me uh no but the most
uncomfortable thing I've ever saw on
Twitter was it was a tweet from Ethan
Klein of h3h3 um and I'm I'm sorry for
everyone that is reminded of this tweet
but it really existed which was a gif
and he said uh every time Ela is
ovulating and it was a gift of someone
filling Donuts I think Boston cream
donuts I'm just like why why
would you do this why and I was just
like Ethan just wanted everyone to know
he's hitting that and man he has been
muted ever since
people oh my God anyway I just wanted to
remind everyone
how many donuts were bought on that day
because of that post probably not many
you know I didn't go I didn't look at
that and was like I want a Boston cream
donut right now oh I don't okay dude
that's the worst thing you've seen on
Twitter by the way so when I first saw
this I was like there's no [ __ ] way I
ever tweeted that
even immediately was insistent in our
group chat he's like I never said that I
never tweeted that I denied it all the
way and all of us were like uh uh we
remember that actually and then I went
and looked and so if if you guys
remember it I guess it did have an
impact on you
yeah it was before
I remembered it it was it pretty nasty
it was no it was just like oh
I'm gonna think about it for a minute
but I think okay so
okay so I was like that's disgusting
he's right but when I saw the tweet I
was like no this actually is funny yeah
I thought it was pretty PG he tapped out
early he missed the pesto and the
prolapses and all that yeah yeah you've
tweeted way worse yeah bro are you even
on Tick Tock do you know anything about
Howie Mandel dude
I think what happened here he made it
sound worse in my opinion although he
described it relatively perfectly
um
this clip was going viral
ELO says I remember it no she's here
yeah she's in the chat we were talking
about like our fertility issues and
stuff so I wasn't trying to be like yo
I'm hitting it I was just making a joke
obviously
[Music]
that's so disgusting though like the
video itself is disgusting not what I
said
okay
and so I said when Ela is ovulating
which is yeah I'm pretty nasty but it's
not that bad Mark right I mean you're
gearing up to show your dick what's the
big deal
how prude are you you're showing your
[ __ ] debt bro
or actually you're not showing your dick
because your fans failed to get you to
number one loser L thumb
so
so I'm muted on uh on on Twitter by Mark
there
shame
bro what's the big deal this is the
worst thing you've seen
[ __ ] someone said Ethan dodging
accountability what do you want me to
say it's a [ __ ] joke about filling up
donuts it's gross I agrees it's gross
that's the joke
I know what are you talking about you
replied the next day and you said I'm so
sorry this is really disgusting oh were
people angry at me yeah
God I don't remember it all oh [ __ ]
sometimes you gotta take this is why I
don't I'm not on Twitter anymore by the
way
well I mean you are on Twitter but you
use it twice
these kinds of tweets yeah well
apparently I lost a mark you know good
friend of mine good guy now I'm on mute
at least it wasn't an unfollow it was
just just a mute it's not that harsh
yeah if he knew he knows if he
unfollowed me war no I'm just kidding I
hate when people get angry about
unfollowing on Twitter it's so stupid
like bro you're not entitled to me to
follow you forever
I literally have gotten into beefs
because I unfollowed on people on
Twitter because they're annoying on
Twitter
again I don't follow the guy anything
for views that guy got so [ __ ] pissed
at me because I unfollowed him on
Twitter because his tweets were annoying
me that's it what do you want
literally posts he posts his ball sack
on Twitter right so you know what I mean
Mark give me a break
you want to see a you want to see
something gross all I [ __ ] green bruh
and I posted that [ __ ]
this is nothing man
oh all right um
we are at a
break time
let's do a poll is this was Mark Wright
to mute me yes or no it was Mark right
to mute Ethan for this tweet
yes no
yeah but you know you you put yourself
out there it's a little bit of a risky
joke I guess you could say and then
you're losing friends all of a sudden
you know I don't think it was that
harmful he was harmless it's you know
the craziest thing he's seen on Twitter
okay well
45 say yes
but the majority knows have it Mark
you're [ __ ] prude they do oh well I
was so offended anyway here's my [ __ ]
if you anyway I was so offended by this
safe for work gift anyway if you can get
me to number one I'll show you my dick
and balls
how dare you Ethan
take a look at my shaven [ __ ]
how dare you
my name is Markiplier and I will show
you a prolapse if you get me to number
one ow
okay Mark
unmute me dude
he should unmute me don't you guys think
should he unmute me yes or no mute eye
pliers mutoplier we gotta get we need to
resolve this this is [ __ ] up thank you
because I actually hit him up recently
like I don't know a few months ago
asking if he wanted to come back on the
Pod because I didn't talk to him in a
while
he ghosted me
well now we know why but I think you
still get notified if you get a DM even
if yeah yeah I think so so that was like
he's over me bro because of this cream
pie [ __ ]
come on bro
how are you gonna mute me over some
[ __ ] [ __ ] because I nut in my
wife but I'm trying to get a bread oh
how does pregnancy work Mark I don't
[ __ ] know what do you think's
happening when I'm talking about
fertility issues bro is my fertility
issues not important to you sex I'm
trying to talk about something that's
like a good pump for the public good
sexually trying to bring awareness to a
really taboo hard to talk about subject
and you're going to mute me because I
[ __ ] my wife
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
that's goodbye
[Laughter]
oh we're doing memes about me doing
polls we can do one more pull and then
we can go guys let's do one more pull
and then we'll go
uh relax just want to take some pictures
should he unmute me yes or no chill Lou
thank you for this gifted Sparkle
sprickle licks think of it again
yeah as we um
as we set this pull up I want to thank
everyone for their support on the see
you next Tuesday members only podcast
uh it was really nice just I love you
know reading the comments and there's a
great Community there
I did the motivational one and and the
comments were lovely so thank you guys
I'm glad you enjoyed that yeah we're at
80 Mark should unmute me so
legally he has to the cream Pie's in
your corner Mark
I'm handing you the bag of cream and I'm
offering you a donut
do you fill the donut or don't you fill
the donut suck a fat donut okay
[Music]
all right
let's do our sponsors this is me right
now so true
Mark why did you block me it's me it's
me
Mark it's me why did you unmatch me yeah
oh dude what's a cream pie shut up
you're about to show your dick bro in
exchange for goods he's basically
not that there's anything wrong with it
but he's exchanging sexual Deeds for
goods I felt that no that like that has
been somebody told me
there's no way he shows his dick and
balls though right he he said I'll make
only fans if you get me number one that
means dick and balls brother he said the
words tasteful nudes he already has done
that well that's fine I feel like when I
hear nude attached to tasteful that
still means sick yeah yeah
if he didn't do that last time though
right so I think he needs to um I tell
you what bro if he didn't show dick and
balls for that
I think his fans would be pissed I would
be pissed he needs full darnage man it
doesn't have to be erect but like if I
was him I'd at least go semi-chub just
for me tasteful right you have a little
bow tie on it he's got a hang bull tux
he's got to hang it out man
because you don't want to do you don't
want to go out there fully
fully flaccid no you still want it to be
tasteful but you want dong dude yeah
because fully flaccid don't look good on
any man dong eye plier
dongle plier
all right thank you Mark the ball the
cream pie is in your corner fill it up
or don't [ __ ]
so angry about that
thank you to our lovely sponsors folks
an old friend of the show is back Adam
and Eve
[Music]
they're my favorite e-commerce website
love e-commerce
they specialize in e-commerce Adam and
Eve .com
they have a website where they sell
stuff
[Music]
Commerce Commerce people selling stuff
people buying stuff
import export kind of stuff you know
adamandeve.com and the import export
business
they happen to have um
all kinds of of Commerce there slay toys
yes sleigh toys
I mean and not the not the type of not
like race cars you know you know what
I'm saying one could say it's maybe the
type of toys
that a
a grown-up would enjoy so an adult boy
right
but it's mostly I'm just gonna make it
clear
it's a Commerce website
student Commerce they don't do like p
word there at all
it's literally Commerce
right
yeah and actually if you go to
adamandeve.com
they're gonna give you 50 off almost any
item plus free shipping that's
absolutely insane offer oh I'll miss you
use the code H3 at checkout
to get the offer fifty percent off
almost any item plus free shipping fifty
percent off bro that's insane and free
shipping I'm nuts you don't have to
think about it are they even making
money I don't know just giving it out
not our problem but the link in the
description is there guys go ahead and
visit adamandeve.com
almost 50 off almost every damn thing
free shipping my favorite e-commerce
website
we love e-commerce I'm into e-commerce
I have an e-commerce website you do
indeed
love it and uh next up thank you to
hellofresh my goodness everybody's
favorite food all football Troopers love
hellofresh
it's basically a cult at this point we
love hellofresh the pictures we get from
pooper Troopers are delectable
delightful delicious looking nutritious
let's take a look
dude some of this [ __ ] looks so freaking
good
damn
here's what hellofresh does they deliver
you
a box
of Iced Out fresh ingredients straight
Garden to table
um
they give you the exact amount you need
to cook the meal so you don't have to
there's no waste and actually what that
ends up doing is it ends up saving you a
lot of money it's actually cheaper than
going out it's even cheaper than grocery
store or shopping because you don't have
to buy
like a whole [ __ ] old school barrels
you know like the barrels they've Rode
In The Hobbit what do you call that just
a barrel a wooden barrel like a wine
barrel you know like you don't have to
buy a whole one of those full of carrots
just for one carrot you know what I mean
right Oh you mean like a pallet no he
means a barrel no no not a pallet a
barrel
so it's actually cheaper than grocery
shopping it's a hell of a lot more
convenient and what's great is the meals
are so good
super healthy super balanced and you
cook them yourself but it's foolproof
they send you an instruction card they
tell you exactly how to cook it they
tell you about that one's a b made that
that's yours right
that's right
that looks so good how was it oh I'm
sorry the burger no the burger is not
mine but wait what you took a photo I
did make the same one though but yeah it
was the same item but that one was from
a fan yes oh crazy
how was it though it was great yeah we
have clear the instructions are both
Burgers turned out beautifully
interesting yeah true yeah um
yeah the card tells you about the food
tells you how to cook it in a way like
it's good for beginners and experts
alike it's just fun
uh here's one you made it love it man I
really love it subscribe to hellofresh
and check save money off your fall to-do
list hellofresh is 25 cheaper than take
out and less expensive in the grocery
store
said that
oh hellofresh now offers vegan recipes
on the menu every week made without
animal products of any kind like Dairy
meat eggs or honey enjoy meals like
sweet chili tofu bowls or spicy coconut
curry stir-fry
guys here's where it gets good this
offer help go to hellofresh.com H uh
hello
hellofresh.com 65h3
swear to God it was H3 what why they do
this
they switched them for no reason
okay
just click the link in the description
if you're confused but hellofresh.com
65h3 and use the code
65h3 for 65 off plus free shipping come
on
I actually had it the wrong way around
the description too oh thank you yeah I
just flipped it around [ __ ]
well it's kind of hard come on can we
just stick with one guys
well luckily the food is consistently
delicious yeah unlike the promo code
which is delicious it's not consistent
go to hellofresh.com
65h3 and use code 65h3 for 65 off plus
free shipping America's number one meal
kit it's hella fresh and we love them
thank you
absolutely
[Music]
absolutely love them
okay
[Music]
oh come on come on
oh so there's another thing I want to
touch on real fast George Floyd's family
is suing Kanye
for 250 million
because of his interview on drink Champs
where he said
George Floyd died of Fentanyl and drug
overdose and not because of the cop that
on video before all of our eyes
dug his knee it didn't that [ __ ]
go to jail like isn't he in jail yeah
yeah so it's like dude he's been
convicted he's serving time
he's in jail and he's out here talking
about how it that guy's innocent how
more depraved can you be what a freak
yeah so his uh they're suing him and I
mean it's interesting it's kind of
reminding me
of the Alex Jones things a little bit
where you're spouting off these
conspiracy theories right
it's less it's less I think less
damaging I mean Alex Jones
uh followers you know Mass harass those
families uh I I don't know if anything
like that has happened it probably
hasn't even been long enough for I mean
they they might be able to prove that
they're being harassed by Kanye fans
although I don't think Kanye's the
difference was like Alex Jones was
accusing the parents of participating in
this right and conspiracy so there's no
lawsuit filed and I was reading up some
legal opinions about this and at least
at least the way these articles are
written about suing for defamation it
seemed like that was not likely to be
right YouTube for defamation because
he's dead exactly for something else
right
and also I think the fact that uh Kanye
so consistently says crazy ass [ __ ] and
has for years even though obviously yes
Jones escalated quite a bit well yeah
that's true so is Alex Jones but I think
the difference here is that he's not
accusing his family of participating in
a cover-up
he said they're using the family so I
think that's probably going to cover his
ass but he's still a piece of [ __ ] for
sure [ __ ] this guy
what is wrong with this man dude
a lot when's Valencia going to ask him
to stop wearing their [ __ ] by the way
Valencia and the Jews what
I think they did come out and we're
talking about dropping him right I know
that no I think that was Adidas yeah
really I don't think he's associated
with uh Balenciaga he just wears their
[ __ ]
I think
I don't know
oh one other really incredible
Revelation before we move on to our poot
of Lovato PowerPoint presentation
is we've talked a lot about gambling on
Twitch it was recently banned as you
guys remember and train wreck I have
come out and basically proclaimed that
he's the biggest piece of [ __ ] in the
world
this guy is
uh
he really is a low-life fan he's been
basically the biggest person gambling
he has told us that he makes a million a
month
and he is always telling his fans that
he's losing money he goes I'm losing
money guys don't Gamble
here he comes out and says this now tell
me what you guys think about this listen
[ __ ] first of all listen here
here's what I'll do folk I got you on
your trip I believe you want some news
to forget about everything you're
talking about here you go
I'll release what I got paid since the
beginning of my contract I've been paid
360 million dollars
for 16 months of gambling there you go
there was the information I'll get you
off the topic of hating poke wait is
that really
cool now you're
not yeah now you made it worse no one's
hating
[Laughter]
there you go
yo by the time please bro it's done 360
million there you go dumb [ __ ] I could
buy Hassan Pokey and Ludwig all together
and sell them and buy them again
[ __ ] [ __ ] you do that to me so much
more than that because I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't even like sell their soul
and all their fans out okay first of all
again this guy's the worst person in the
world he's literally a villain how are
you gonna call them [ __ ] for not
exploiting their fans
[ __ ] [ __ ] broke idiots first of
all do you believe this 360 million
that would make him like one of the
richest people in the country
like top 250 potentially
that's a little funky don't you think
seems
seems hard to believe yeah I don't know
I don't know how much of that was
immediately fed back into them though
like yeah he was paid 360 million he
says because we've always been the same
time yeah he was gambling with house
money which he always vehemently denied
okay well regardless of if so that's 22
and a half million dollars a month
for 16 months he posted a tweet like
within the last half hour addressing it
maybe give you guys some context
I I think that's like his income and
then he has like expenses which is
gambling it for promotion all right okay
but that's not his net profit yeah okay
but like
even if he lost a couple million a month
it's really a negligible amount well he
loses probably a meal per day
a cup like so
over time I think that kind of adds up
to at least half there's no [ __ ] shot
he loses a million a day
yeah every bet is like tens of thousands
of dollars and it only takes a few
seconds
according to him he's getting 22 and a
half million dollars a month okay
so that would basically he wouldn't
really
oh someone said there's 600 plus
billionaires in the US so I would be in
the thousandth uh area there
in terms of how wealthy he is but
I just love how
he's such a piece of [ __ ] he really has
no morals At All by the way the IRS is
going to have some questions about that
360. I wonder if he's been uh declaring
all that
he better be God damn that's a lot of
money to [ __ ] around with
but just imagine how much money his fans
are losing can you imagine
yeah I mean if that is true
if we just take it at face value
then you have to extrapolate that stake
is making significantly more money off
of that off of the amount of people that
he's directing their way dude how many
lives have you ruined
like literally just you took all your
fans and you
grab them by the by the feet and just
yank them upside down bro
tell me how many active fans do you
think he has love
like viewers yeah just active how many
fans are out there that regularly watch
ing well he has he regularly has 30k so
probably a hundred thousand because
those viewers like rotate sure
so let's say 360 million divided by a
hundred thousand let's see how much per
so per viewer on average he cost them
or he made three thousand six hundred
dollars off every viewer on average
actually I believe that
um lifetime earnings on gambling is
really high obviously because it's super
addictive
and people get sucked in super easily
there it is man and watch how he's
trying to spin it too he's on Twitter
responding to people talking about it
yeah so he tweeted this twit longer he
opened it up and it just leads to a
YouTube link which leads to the end of
The Dark Night when uh
yeah Morgan Freeman's walking away as
this blows up oh yeah good
but he's like escaping steak like a
steak is the bat cave uh I don't know
they I think today is when they
officially enforce the apology uh
apology what the [ __ ] the policy on
Twitch so maybe this is him just setting
things on fire before he leaves I don't
know
before he stops streaming it I think
Joker please tell me the IRS is
investigating this
he's in Canada
yeah but he made a lot of that money in
America
it's their business
he only recently moved to Canada I
thought I mean it was like a year ago
now but I mean yeah he was doing it at
one point in America you're right
um Joe God and I almost just died of
cringe right there that was brutal
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] Bro [ __ ] You Dan
where was the one I saw a response where
he was like actually I was doing good
for people
you guys got to watch this
this guy's such a deluded freak
actually the biggest biggest piece of
[ __ ]
um
somebody said Canada has IRS too do they
have it's probably called something
different though
yeah
the CRA oh that sounds CRA is coming for
you mm-hmm they're both coming
here it is check that check how diluted
this [ __ ] psycho is
this guy goes
this by the way who is his own alt he
wrote this himself I honestly love train
wreck and I don't care if he earned 360
million streaming I watched him to
fulfill my gambling addiction and
watching him lose eight hours a day in
and out made me not want to gamble
either he helped so many people so I'm
happy for him train wreck said plus one
this is more the case than the narrative
is sold but it is what it is be sure to
get the help you need and watching
streamers is only a temporary Crush
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] you made 360 [ __ ]
million dollars you're gonna act like
you're the good guy like oh people are
just here for the therapy of not
gambling you [ __ ] Goblin
are you serious dude don't listen if
you're gonna walk away 360 million
dollars don't [ __ ] lie to yourself at
least know that you basically [ __ ]
over so many people
okay let's not pretend like you're the
good guy dude
please bro
this was written by like steaks Russian
PR Company
psychotic take
also like there's substantially more
people who watch his Clips where he wins
like millions of people sees those clips
that don't see him losing this is the
main issue with gambling because people
just see the good right those clips have
like literally millions of views when he
wins like 10 million uh those are not
even his fans so they don't even know
what he's saying
your heartbeat is elevating
yeah it's people are saying it's pretty
high I I think
no when when you're 21 apparently it can
go up to like 140. I'm just resting yeah
21. you can be super high there it is
he's in the prime of his life babies
going dude I think I'd have a heart
attack with my heart well also this is
not technically resting I'm like on
screen and stuff and that probably
juices me up a little bit that's wow
normally yeah
mine is 64 right now
how do you know my Apple watch
oh I want to know what mine is I think
mine's like 70 or something I'm very
anxious person too so when I'm on stream
I get a little bit nervous oh it went
down though yo that's what happened when
you were talking it went up
by like and now it's going back down to
a normal rate you getting all hyped up
boy when you're on stranded yeah right I
was wrong mine's 88. oh okay 65 like 64
is my resting heart rate you're also
older than me that you mean like when
you're sleeping thanks for reminding me
yeah you got an old man heart so I slept
with this old man so maybe that's what
it's from old man old man I guess God I
don't know what mine is I I wish I knew
I've had this on when I go go peeing I
accidentally left it on and I saw the
stream afterwards and it went up to like
150. just let your peeing yeah dude
that poor old heart of ours man it goes
through so much on a day-to-day basis
yeah yeah
yeah here is uh because he's the hero
twitch deserves but not the one it needs
right now who the [ __ ] is full Squad
gaming
I'm not sure are they really you know
these people are just looking for like a
donation bro he responded to this with
the laughing crying face yeah
had to let the people know [ __ ] you're
bro come on just tell it just say it
like it is you want him to send you
money
it's the only reason anyone's nice to
him
yep there it is train wreck the biggest
piece of [ __ ] in the world let him you
know [ __ ] them
ugly you are disgusting I'm gonna kill
you give me two hundred dollars
that's yeah
exactly
so 360 million you guys think that's
real huh
yeah but I don't think it's net profit
I'm skeptical yeah me too and yeah
regardless of what it is um yeah loves
right that that
is probably including all of the money
that he was given to use on the site
yeah who wants me to take their money
I love that sound myself who wants to
lose some money today
Cheyenne said Ethan I've been doing the
Metamucil fiber powder between meals
uh also I've been eating better and
getting more active so far I've lost six
pounds [ __ ] family dude let's go
Cheyenne
yeah dude I'm on track man I'm doing the
weight loss is good it's going good
weighed myself this morning I was under
two
30 for the first time since I started
and the last time I was at 2 30 was when
I didn't eat for two days when I was
like sick literally did not eat for two
days
and now I'm eating again
and now I'm below 2 30.
let's go
what's my weight goulded Mayo up your
Dome Dan
200.
200. yes sir Dan should mail up that
Dome
that's going to be a long journey but I
can do it you can do it it's 30 pounds
tiny little twink by then boy [ __ ]
so thankful H3 I love you guys helping
me through a lot right now love you so
much love you Holly shout out Holly
Ethan uh John says Ethan and I have not
been listening to your advice and I am
up five pounds well there it is let's go
John that's [ __ ] hey at least you're
enjoying yourself man games dude eating
food gaining weight like obviously like
mentally it's horrible but man it's so
fun just eating [ __ ] food
so good I love food
if there was like some kind of pill you
could take to like speed up your meta I
don't know I mean there's math there is
I was about to say amphetamines are
pretty good for that actually yeah
there's stuff like that so I guess it's
not really a good option regardless yeah
but boy if it was up to me man I'd be
eating ooh I'd be eating damn would you
say that you're a binge eater like when
when you just like so let's say you have
like you order McDonald's and like an
hour later you're like okay let's order
something else is is that an issue for
you actually not I've never been like a
binge eater like that
I just like would eat constantly
throughout the day I don't know like
insatiable appetite before I started the
Wellbutrin I had I can't emphasize this
I had zero control I could not stop
eating like I it was it's hard to
describe I couldn't help my impulses I
had no control over it like I would
think about losing weight all day it was
the last thing on my mind every night
before what's a bad about how [ __ ] how
[ __ ] up I did that day how I'm never
gonna lose weight out tomorrow I really
got to try harder and every day I could
not control myself I'm talking eating
all day and then at like 2 A.M having a
nasty [ __ ] up snack and while I'm
eating it I know how [ __ ] up it is but
it's so hard to explain I just had no
[ __ ] control left so weird
before I started the Lexapro
I was always pretty in control of my
weight I feel like more or less
it's just it's hard to explain I mean
and you feel so weak but
like I just couldn't control it man it
was crazy I might for me personally my
problem is binge eating so tell me about
what that looks like so like
which I'm actually
following on following your advice and
I'm actually down some weight like I
said clothes are starting to fit again
I'm not binge eating I'm I'm keeping it
to some Square meals good so like on the
weekends I would order Chick-fil-A
which is bad in itself yeah and then
like an hour later even though my body
is not physically hungry my brain's like
I need more food need more food need
more food so then I'd order McDonald's
oh that's pretty that's pretty good yeah
so it's just the binging and the
accessibility to like doordash and [ __ ]
like you know oh my God yeah doordash
I spent a fall a small fortune on
doordash and Postmates and all that [ __ ]
boy yeah
but yeah the Wellbutrin gave me like
control of my
and actually what's so interesting yeah
so wellbutrin's actually FDA approved
for both
um weight loss and quitting smoking and
when I did that I was able to quit both
like it really gave me
the agency to do that
so interesting you know I used to you
you saw Zach I couldn't resist going and
having that cigarette with you right
right and that was another thing that I
just hated I knew I had to quit I'm
getting too old for this [ __ ] and uh I
don't I just I got no problem with it
now man oh that's [ __ ] amazing I'm
proud of you
thanks bro but yeah try that Wellbutrin
I'm on 300 milligrams someone else
Lexapro Wellbutrin bro
that's that good cocktail
uh thank you my fiance has been uh with
for 15 years and banned me in my sleep
last December
they just bailed when you're sleeping
[ __ ] up
I've been 40 pound I've lost 40 pounds
since then not a recommended weight loss
method
oh just because you've been so stressed
yeah
yeah but at least you're a skinny Legend
you might be single but you're a skinny
Legend
but that's a consolation
[Applause]
uh Caroline says for me Ethan's the only
one who could describe what food
addiction was like I've always yo-yo to
my weight anyway I'm on Wellbutrin now
and losing five pounds a month that's
what's up
it's 5 000 times easier with mental
health treatment yeah I don't know what
it's so interesting man
five pounds a month is great that's a
good pace
Gabriella said I tape I take now track
zone for binge eating disorder helped me
lose 30 pounds damn
yo thank God we live in this age of
Medicine
Nicole says I'm on Lexapro before
starting it I never ate sweets or cared
about snacks after starting it I
literally wake up in the middle of the
night to snack and have insane cravings
for sweets yeah dude
yeah man well if you find that you're
eating too much and gaining weight you
may want to ask your psychiatrist about
Adam Wellbutrin made a huge difference
from here
oh Chris house says intermittent fasting
has helped me lose eight pounds in the
last three weeks
you think you should give it a shot
um I've tried that for me what's working
is
honestly I'm just living my life I'm
eating what I want
and I'm just being more responsible
eating less and exercising every day
to
like if I want a burrito or if I want
Mexican food I'll do that I'll just eat
less food
in the morning you know
I feel like when go ahead love start
sorry no go ahead okay
I feel like when I push myself too hard
like put these crazy rules on myself
I'll end up like giving up two weeks
later but if I kind of find this in
between thing where I'm kind of giving
up some stuff but not too much I can
like kind of do it for a longer time
without giving up yeah I found that for
myself too
yeah it's just um yeah I'm I'm eating
whatever I want it's just like if you
eat something with a lot of calories in
it you just know you're not gonna be
able to eat as much food later
so you kind of gotta
I'm gonna eat your ass yeah eating ass
is a calorie-free snack
is poop have calories it must I wonder
how much calories and poop of course
how many calories if you eat an ass is
that online is it an answer I mean
you do that I don't think Duty
after years of struggling with eating
disorders from don't let me watch this
embodies more but I finally got into
treatment this February it's never too
late and you are worthy of recovery I've
loved that
you know I waited so long before I got
on the Wellbutrin I was gaining 80
pounds with this [ __ ] and I don't know
why I waited so long
but I'm so glad that I did and that's
the story with the with the Lex bro too
I waited way too long before I got on
that I don't know why
it's just it's a weird thing right you
don't want to admit that you that you
need help
uh Britney's one month nicotine free we
love that
Alyssa says I up my Lexapro because my
anxiety kept creeping back and I
actually am eating less because my
anxiety caused me to eat for Comfort
right
yeah I raised my Lexapro too I started
at 10.
milligrams and I raised it to 20.
and that's where I found that it's
that I'm feeling like you know good
what were you going to say something
Abby I was just going to say that uh
having an Apple Watch has helped me keep
up with exercise I hate wearing watches
and stuff but uh I got this one like a
week ago and it's good like the app to
track my exercising every day I feel
inclined to fill the little bubble on it
each day so I found that helpful but I
know you don't like wearing watches but
it detracts your steps like how does it
track your exercise uh yeah track steps
has a lot of features in here EKG and uh
heart rate monitor and a few other ones
this is the new one but it's way too
[ __ ] big I feel like I'm walking
around with like a computer on my wrist
probably gonna exchange it for a smaller
what else you use it for that big old
thing all right it's convenient when I
go on a run I don't have to take my
phone with me because that's good yeah I
could play all my music answer my calls
and text from it it has a cellular so
by the way uh Happy Birthday Jesse
Jensen 31st okay Playgirl love that
Chris house says I if you eat three
times a day in an eight hour window you
will increase your metabolism the first
time I did the intermittent fasting I
lost 30 pounds great
different things work for different
people you know if that's what it takes
I think for me it wasn't about the
technique at all it was just about the
the impulse you know what I mean
so there it is weight loss kings and
queens out there that's what I'm talking
about let's go
keep it going
um all right you guys want to do uh
Natalie is advocating for ketamine
psychedelic therapy
yeah that's a super interesting new
thing going on we talked about that with
kalila
apparently ketamine helps with
depression isn't that weird
[ __ ] crazy
uh let's do this let's do this poot
Lovato we've been putting it off for
long enough oh my God it's finally
happening been in the works for weeks
now oh right this is a segment we have
meme history
the great memes of history that you may
have missed or you may like to be
refreshed on that's right poot
Lovato now I had seen this photo
[Music]
but I didn't know it was called put
Lovato I'm very excited I have gone out
of my way to not look this up I still
don't really I know it has something to
do with Demi yeah oh you you don't know
the picture I dude the picture is so
[ __ ] funny it's
it is so funny and then I had a hard
time the rest of the weekend one of my
fun one of my most fun experiences on
the internet sure was during the poop
era yeah yes was there just lots of good
memes incredible memes also just once
something is happening on the like
Twitter verse if you say it like I was
in high school when it happened if you
you know who who was your friend when
you say fruit and everyone's like
right that's how you find your friends
got it yeah
well okay so so poop this is where we
begin uh Demi has changed her pronouns
back to she her hers thank you luckily
for me
can I can I ask a question I don't want
to be rude about it
I want to be respectful as I can
every every time you lead off with a
statement like that yeah
look I tried I try so hard to be
sensitive to the pronouns and stuff like
she was going by they them and I tried
so hard to accommodate her and after all
the [ __ ] work I put in she's going
back to she her like big trouble I feel
like you gotta commit if you change your
pronouns yeah you gotta commit harder
than that or maybe like a cool down
period that's what kind of game you know
like the spell has a cool down change
your pronouns but it's like it's like a
five-year cooldown yeah the the queer
Community has also expressed
um confusion and possibly anger about
like
Demi were confused it doesn't seem that
genuine when you're switching it every
year that is what people and upset and
also you can't get angry at people
you're like you didn't get my [ __ ]
pronouns right when it's like well last
year were they them now you're she Hurts
Like You Gotta [ __ ] help me out here
lady
people are saying nope you guys are
saying bad take how uh genuinely it's a
good take I'm sorry
I'm sorry because if you expecting
someone like me who's a boomer to use
the right pronouns and I'm trying my
best I am trying my best okay you can't
be flip-flopping every [ __ ] week man
stop with the L take you know I'm right
the be reasonable yes the if someone
goes by they them and then they decide
to switch their pronouns it's all a
singular experience Demi's case in
particular
um let me get for sure what she said but
it was something along the lines of like
nobody got it so
and that's why people expressed concern
about that there's lots of passion in
the comments here
as a person who tries his best to be an
ally I'm just saying maybe she should
think harder about the they them switch
before she goes because clearly if she's
switching back like a year later
you know yeah and the implications of
like the community you say you're
identifying with for sure yeah you're
just going to leave them behind
guys how is it a bad take you know I'm
right
people are saying it's a bad poll though
dude
no what that's a fine poem the audience
ah they're confused
um yeah Demi Lovato states that they
have been feeling more feminine and
that's why okay good you know and and
obviously I'm not saying you can't
change your identity of how you identify
that's perfectly fine
but don't get angry if I can't keep
track of your pronouns man I left yogurt
store and didn't get the yogurt that I
wanted my pronoun is yogurt store and
then I had a hard time the rest of the
weekend
I don't know what that means
yeah but if you're offended by what I
just said
listen
you're doing a war of PR we're trying to
make trans people more accepted in
society
and I'm right there with you bro
and non-binary people yes however if you
keep switching
because you don't necessarily have a
very concrete reason
it's confusing and it elicits questions
I think
look at my hair you're saying that I'm
not
an ally what does that mean
does that mean
it's not true yeah I guess that means
something should
all right
anyways
to be offensive I'm Sorry by the way
maybe for that joke although I don't
think I interpreted the right okay I was
saying look at me look look at my hair
you're taking me a little too serious
that's what I was trying to get across I
don't know where the Ally thing came
from yeah that was that was maybe
abh trans people
I'll just throw them under the bus right
now
you can never keep track of pronouns
like me rewind I hit the X
nobody keeps track of pronouns like me
you understand all right Demi's back to
she her hers okay good let's move on
so do you want to lead us through this
uh Olivia I can take the round no you
can take the reins and then if you have
any questions okay so the birthplace of
Pooh
it was a night like any other November
13 2014.
Demi was participating in The Royal
Variety of performance at the Palladium
Theater
[Music]
as you can see she looks slay she looks
great she does look great love the dress
serving boots
loving that so it makes it funny yeah
she looks great
uh the character poot was actually
a result
of a photo taken by an unknown cell
phone user on the red carpet hmm
okay so here she is looking slay as
Olivia said
and we don't know we don't know the
identity of the shooter this is The
Classy Knoll this is the photo we know
that right that is the phone that is the
hand the shot heard around the world so
that's so the whose mother is that hand
that's interesting so we don't know who
took this photo
[Music]
I think it was uh who's the guy that
shot JFK Lee Harvey we don't know that's
the thing we don't know I think those
Lee Harvey Oswald
that's what they want you to think okay
here it is Lucia there she is John
Hinckley okay this is important now Dan
everyone pay attention George Bush
phone Demi
now let's meet her
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is poop yeah oh it's a pleasure to
meet you pick the worst photo ever taken
of a human being
the energetic scene bro it's such a
horrible photo look at this
okay
and then
so this photo
do we know where it was first posted yes
it's next wait hold on did they [ __ ]
with her face when we get to it okay
there's a lot to unpack
moving on poop
ladies and gentlemen wow that delivered
on the build up we've been talking about
poop for like a month
first surfaced on Tumblr rest in peace
still there but it's not yeah it's not
the same enough very important I'll tell
you yeah exactly true
uh if first serviced and Tumblr in 2015
it's caption read Demi's twin sister
she was locked in the basement her whole
life this picture was taken the first
time she went outside her name is poot
Demi's twin sister yeah so so
wow so that post must have gone crazy
because here's the thing is like
that is obviously true like you look at
that photo and you know that is poot
yeah that's poot that's someone I've
never met before and that is poot that's
just so interesting I wonder where they
got the photo was this the photographer
I think I think yes I think the
photographer probably is the one who but
what a legend because he's so funny and
like wow what a guy man
obviously it went viral pootie and the
Beast
Hooter pan right
Harry pooter
this poot fan art also went viral
I love Demi so much I had to draw her
she's my queen
that's actually pretty good
representation yeah nailed it
it was later revealed the poot is an
edit okay devastating though unimportant
right that's funny because I've never
seen this photo I've only ever seen this
photo
that's so genius what did they do they
just widened her face it's like all the
edits people do baby
yeah I feel I feel her pain and you feel
seen right now it's so subtle it's so
subtle but so good
he did her so dirty man
sucks when people do that so how can put
be applied to our real lives that is the
question indeed
ethood
this of course was edited like hers wait
no I think this is the original we're
gonna see the editor no this one was
added no that's the original photo and
then oh this is but that okay who I
don't like Photo next dude
look like a [ __ ] whale you don't like
this photo absolutely not so funny and
the caption that someone put on the
server it was so perfect it's like Zach
looks like the uncle that calls you
chemo Sawa or something and it's not
Uncle it's like the guy who just had sex
but the whole just the posture the body
language it's all happening for me like
a whale
not about that yeah the way that you do
self-assigned Poots I feel like it's
when the way that a b described it when
his photo went viral where it's like
that is a photo of me but that is not me
right and so I tried to gather those
forever this is nice yeah I like what
you're doing here
except out of all these I think this is
the only one that this one
that's just a picture that is the
original yeah that's just a picture of
me actually but that was me at my chunky
big fat boy fit that was like that
podcast was that was the wake-up call
that was a big one right yeah
that's also the corner of a fisheye lens
I think it just distorts its life yeah
it's the right of the story exactly like
that yeah you know I was a [ __ ]
monster
I still am that's what's so crazy
[Music]
uh loot loot give me the loot
this is a real photo this is a boot and
they're boots
so me and you uh a b tell me about it
we're the two unedited Kings
has been in a downward spiral since this
picture
this is such an iconic photo though
maybe oh what are you
yeah sure yes sir
I got another Hot Chip left over if you
wanna
revisit how much how much you said you
wouldn't do it for a million dollars
last time now would you do it for a
thousand no really
nope
I would do it again
Dan you need to do it you [ __ ]
how much you pen
nobody else got paid
so
I'll give you 200 harder than them 200
now I'm not trying to pay out worth it
how much you need to read a Hot Chip
right now I'll do it for a thousand
I'm not paying your ass a thousand
dollars well then I ain't in no Hot Chip
boy
this is [ __ ] everyone ate the Hot
Chip Dan
sucks for them
Lena one got a GG
oh
what are you saying no I'm just saying
you're gonna get a thousand bucks when
you I'm trying to Define your girl I
thought you were saying I should do it
again I won't wait wait what'd you say
about Lena I I'm saying Dan's turning
down for a thousand when Lena wanted to
go to GG
she wanted a GG she won the contest and
didn't win a prize I'm saying I'm saying
no one won anything you saying he didn't
pay anyone I said nobody got anything
right
yeah that's what I said yeah we're on
your suckers we're on the same page I'm
trying to say yeah we are on the same
page you [ __ ] upood
Lena you wouldn't do it again
oh that's interesting because you're the
reigning champ
yeah it's just I don't
mean again you had a hard time
afterwards it was just a one and done
yeah
you know I would do it again I think I
could beat you Lena with my out my
throat pain I was thinking because I was
really sick and I had a really sore
throat I think I could beat you if I did
again okay if you wanted to compete I'll
do it again you would yeah I would
because that would be fun actually
by the way here is a another angle
of Demi's legendary photo
that's good
that's really good comes out of the the
basement with that do
inute EDU
wait that's really cam or Cam no that's
cool that's cool all right that's coot
sorry it's our boy Cooter Cameron is
very nice he is he's a good guy
foreign
for a cursed photo of you and that's
what he gave me
it's not that bad I don't even remember
this it's not edited like no no no no
it's just when there's like it's a
cursed image
and that's what your husband delivered
so it's not my problem thank you baby
what do we think is this is this cursed
we need a better curse of Lena
and Cam I think oh I got plenty of
course photos of me I can get you one
right now hold on drop it this is uh
just oot
this is not a bad photo this is also not
cursed but I feel like I I look like of
course you did the presentation
I was saying that I was having a hard
time because I've deleted all the photos
I hate of myself very interesting
here's a good photo of me
and friend of the show
hawut man dude
what do we do about it
you know it's kind of a fire angle when
you just see my
[Music]
I don't know
there it is so we love you Pooh can't
wait to see you next time Demi lets you
outside love and hugs H3 crew
thank you thank you that was fun hey
an excellent time
happy you liked it Dan you were talking
about how the show's light today and you
won't even eat a spicy chip
but you know about the show I didn't say
that I wouldn't eat it I said I would
eat it for 1 000 USD okay what about
five hundred dollars
no I think a thousand sounds very fair
yeah I changed actually you know what it
I don't even want to go down this path
because if I convince you then I
actually have to do it and I I got a
plan
leftovers tonight but then we got a bank
not being in the bathroom for Friday Dan
died
if leftovers wasn't at 10 A.M I might be
more considering it more seriously but
oh Cam poor cam is sending me all these
cursed photos of him cam had an amazing
blow up
slay that's not me that's cool that's
cool that's my uh twin brother did cook
get like the Accutane or some kind of
treatment or did this clear up on its
own just cleared up on its own thank
Christ your skin is beautiful now your
skin is beautiful now look at you oh my
God it healed so beautifully what the
heck no scarring nothing I can imagine
that must have been a really hard time
bro oh you don't know the half of it but
you know now I'm all embarrassed but
thank you that guy [ __ ] cam that's coot
cute you made it bro you grew up and now
look at you man you don't have to be
that awesome like high school and middle
school feels so serious right and if
sometimes it sucks so [ __ ] bad and it
feels like it's your whole damn life I
don't even barely remember school now
but look at you this kid grew up
he's a beautiful Swan now he's just a
man-child oh my God a child I
I just saw something that I have to
share with you Ethan
mm-hmm
I I didn't see this until just now
your mom sent me a message
I'm sorry to hear about you and Ethan
having a falling out your relationship
is similar to a marriage in a way you
guys need counseling lol whatever you
decide just know you'll be sorely missed
so sweet Donna you're such a sweetheart
and then she followed it up a few
minutes later oh my God Dan you really
had me fooled
oh [ __ ]
how does she keep falling for it though
she says you guys sold it pretty well
like especially you Ethan you I mean you
had most of the chat full too yeah I saw
everyone at that but I I just
you should just okay all right I guess
maybe you're right but how many times
you're gonna click bait this crazy ass
[ __ ] yeah I'm sorry to do that to you
Donna something happens
nobody's gonna believe us
so every time I meet my grandma
she'll ask about either like you and Ila
why you guys broke up
no joke she's also the similar age as
your your mom uh I think it might be
something with age because every single
time I meet her maybe once or a couple
times a month she'll ask something about
a thumbnail and a title
that's funny man I mean at least she's
like looking at the thumbnails and
titles she's keeping up a little bit
Yeah but she doesn't watch the show I
think she's literally not maybe she does
well I don't know at least my mom she
did watch because she got the reveal
yeah hi Mom by the way
if you're watching still
that was a nice message she sent you
though Dan yeah that's very sweet
dubrick
dubrick dubrick
okay there it is okay
wait is this related maybe yeah this is
another mom that fell for it oh my gosh
sorry to Mom's everywhere
uh this is from Jessie she said
her mom said I think Dan quit for real
he's trying to get him back no he just
showed up [ __ ]
all right since we're I wasn't gonna
share this but since this seems to be
the theme when I went to the restroom a
minute ago I looked at my phone and I
had a text from my dad
oh he said just is it true and then a
few minutes later oh you didn't quit
oh man I guess we really sold it you
sold it well I'm sorry parents of
America all the parents are reaching I
apologize for putting you guys all
through that
oh
someone just gave 25 zaddy to the fun to
get make Dan eat the Hot Chip I'm not
gonna do it today
[Applause]
maybe I'll do it on Friday do it [ __ ]
right now I do it on Friday yeah
Dan we got to clickbait for real because
I saw like everyone the aftermath fine I
was totally fine I just had a little bit
of a spicy diarrhea yeah well a lot of
them a lot of people on the crew had a
real rough time that afternoon and um
well how are you with spicy food you're
seeing I'm actually really good and I
don't have a weak stomach so it would
probably be okay but
again uh you know I I do all the
planning for leftovers it's an early
morning show my my Wednesday nights are
always pretty late finishing that up and
I cannot be [ __ ] my brains out
tonight so but Friday maybe we got
phones Dan you can do it from the toilet
yeah
foreign
if you go if you end up on the potty I
can cover for you
[Laughter]
I'm telling you I'll do it on Friday
okay Friday that sounds great that's for
one thousand so much to look forward to
that's awesome Friday baby I just can't
wait I'm just so excited
Dan's gonna eat the chip I I'm so
excited you guys for one thousand
dollars that's right well no well who's
paying you a thousand dollars
but somebody is or I'm not even a trip
well here's 10 bucks people keep putting
in I don't know it's Chip phones yeah
now there's a Dan Chip fund
bruh I'd eat that chip for free dude
that ship cost me 10 bucks Dan
can I deduct the 10 for sure okay I'll
do it for 990 dollars
they [ __ ] sell that [ __ ] for 10 I
know bucks I know I know we talked about
already but that is insane one
[ __ ] chip yo
it tastes like [ __ ] too by the way you
imagine working where they make those
that'd be horrible yeah they definitely
have masks or like heavy duties masks
yeah yeah I guess Ranch
foreign
by the way I'm happy to say an update on
her situation she
last we heard she had a false live she's
about to go live and then she just put
up a text and said I'll be back later
the police are here somewhat ominous
but fortunately she's went back on live
and explained that she's doing well and
everything is fine which I'm very
relieved to find out
um
she was very appreciative so here's
actually what happened I found this
interesting
when her husband was yelling at her
apparently she had the stream muted for
several hours and when he started
threatening to kill her dogs and stuff
she just became overwhelmed didn't know
what to do and she just unmuted her
stream yeah crazy he was saying he was
about to Tweet stuff exposing her that
was false to ruin her career and she was
just like Boo nope
[ __ ] and I wasn't clear on this but
just base it sounded like maybe from her
own accounts because he had like access
to them
that anybody else's take away yeah
that's what I yeah yeah right
because I think this dude's trying to
say anonymous
for good reasons right UPS is asking for
you know what I mean
I said UPS what do you want
I didn't say any I didn't say a God damn
[ __ ] thing you sure didn't I'm not
trying to get you to quit again
not to speak if I speak I am in in big
trouble
here she is discussing what happened
yeah
some of you probably saw the other night
uh he called me during stream
and I Disappeared for like two hours
and then I finally like unmuted
about an hour and a half into the call I
guess
and um
I apologize that was hard to watch for
people
I don't really know what else to do
because she was threatening to Tweet
[ __ ] right so kind he was gonna tweet
lies I wanted to beat him to the punch
but um
yeah
sorry for if I triggered anybody with
past abuse
anyway so that happened
that was actually the first time that
he's ever heard himself on a recording
because as I told you guys before
previously when I recorded him he would
just like refuse to listen
to recordings
sometimes with like take phones Etc so I
would never actually hear them
and I think that when he heard himself
on that call it really
sunk in
how much of an [ __ ]
he is
yeah
um she goes on to say that
um
they're separated
she she implies it but I don't think she
directly says it at any point
oh here's a clip let's see
I think that when he hurt himself on
that call
sunk in
how much of an [ __ ]
he is
it's like you never [ __ ] realized
idiot anyways yeah I mean
you were threatening to kill her dogs
and horse
so
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] artist
but I I support amaranth all the way no
matter what whatever she decides to do I
support her you know what I mean I'm not
going to judge her
on whatever route she takes on this one
um
so as of today though I have access to
all of my accounts and finances again
uh he's not here he's getting help and
I'm seeking legal and emotional counsel
I have like I might throw a drink do I
do I stay hydrated I don't know which
one right now
I mean I've had a lot of people reach
out that offer their help and support
including like legal help places to stay
Etc so
I really appreciate that thank you
and I think that way yeah I think if she
if she gets herself a good divorce
lawyer activate
[ __ ] because I think when there's abuse
involved he's not entitled to
he's entitled to a lot less if anything
I think
hope so
good evidence yeah exactly
um
so she got her finances back
and uh yeah
also there's another weird Wrinkle in
this story about her cameraman and this
is so interesting the guy who was
posting updates to Twitter
about how
she's all right
um do we have that one
all of his tweets are in this album yeah
because we pulled it up and I'm like who
is this guy like do we know if this guy
even is like representing
so let me just go to the one he tweeted
and then
yeah he said this one latest update
people on the team were able to talk to
her and says she's fine police were
called multiple times she says she's
okay
she spent all day talking to her husband
to sort things out not sure what else we
can do right now
yeah it turns out that this dude was uh
she says a
uh
betrayed her for clout
was her ex cameraman the real Mars Bar
let's see I don't have any messages
it's kind of crazy
it's like I felt so alone for so long
and now it's like I
I can't stop getting people to talk to
me not in a bad way it's just a very big
contrast I didn't think people cared
that much
um
some people though seem to be using the
situation for personal gain and Cloud
Which is less
less moving
um
unfortunately my cameraman seems to be
one of those people former cameramen
just over the twitchcon weekend
he actually withheld information and sat
on Communications which made certain
situations more explosive than needed to
be
uh so it's kind of weird what he's doing
now
um Sunday night after twitchcon I felt
uncomfortable with like how much he was
a good word for escalating matters
because it was very tense as you saw
from the text messages
partly because of the miscommunications
um
he called security to resolve the
situation forcibly and aggravated it
further when he called police even
though I said I didn't want to do that
it's like I felt like he was attempting
to create a scene at a convention full
of lives streamers like our floor
literally had
streamer staying in it
all up and down the floor
and so
um just feels very shitty because I
expressed clearly I had plans in place
to quietly deal with the situation at
home didn't really appreciate that
uh she's let's see here she says that
this dude
um
it was pretty weird how he was tweeting
out the whole time like without her
consent or permission he starts going
free amaranth
does it make sense and then he took this
weird photo of her and the police and I
guess her husband
and he says does it make sense now why I
had to stream on Kate's Channel all day
Saturday at twitchcon so he was twit
streaming against her will is that what
happened no
um he is her cameraman and so when
things happen with her husband she'll
mute it or the stream keeps going and
she is preoccupied so he continued
streaming
but he didn't he wasn't like a an online
personality also for the Skeptics here's
a picture of amaranth locked out of our
hotel room in the 911 call I made while
he was yelling at her on Monday morning
6 a.m do you find this picture like
like why are you posting that or is that
and why'd you why'd you take it yeah you
took this really weird photo bro why did
you even take that
right
[ __ ]
yeah I don't know though at the other
hand it's like if you're scared
as we all were I don't know but she
didn't like it so she was very
uncomfortable with it
well she said that her cameraman knew
that this had been happening it wasn't
like he took an opportune photo like I
can't believe this is happening I need
to snap this it was like he's been
living with this knowledge for a while
and why is he documenting it definite
creep shot though like whoa
if you scroll to the bottom of the album
you'll see the last tweet where uh
yeah at the very end this is after he
was fired
holy [ __ ] yeah it says x uh cameraman
for amaranth and you see she responded
to this saying stop
to be clear I'm not Amorous content guy
I'm not just her content camera guy
I've known Kade for eight years I'm not
some guy who just started working for a
field for Kate I'm going to support her
no matter what she chooses to do she's
like stop it
bro is he trying to get in there
oh
I didn't I didn't get that I don't think
who knows but my interpretation is is
I mean it sounds like they had a
professional working relationship for an
extended period of time and he was
probably aware of what a shitty abusive
situation this was and
was
for whatever reason because I don't
think we really know what the incident
was that triggered all of this at
twitchcon
but
uh decided against her wishes that he
wanted to get the police involved
um maybe he thought it was going to get
violent or something
um and I think in his mind he was
probably trying to do a good thing
but
like a lot of people online with
vlogitis
you know there's always that angle of
what clout can I get from this and like
if you're really concerned for
somebody's safety and well-being like
that it you don't you don't need to be
live tweeting it and and shouldn't be
really especially if it's against their
wishes so yeah I don't know he had the
exclusive on this [ __ ] like this one had
17 000 likes right
no he was definitely trying to get
something out of it he said after this I
was super stressed about losing my job
after Monday and that stress is what
leads good people to turn a blind eye to
shitty situations I'm glad it's all
coming to light and I'm glad I at least
try to do the right thing what does that
mean
um I think it's him saying that he
wanted to keep his job and he didn't
want to mess with the business model
that was created so that's what he means
by it leads good people to turn a blind
eye and then after Monday he was super
stressed about losing his job because
the business they had been in a huge
fight and there was an altercation
oh
he's like I'm glad the public now sees
what I knew which was that she was
abused oh because he's like they oh I
see he's trying to cover his ass like I
knew the whole time I didn't do anything
yes
well it's not your [ __ ] story to tell
to begin with bro
it's kind of weird if you did
um
okay so there it is there's that that
whole weird thing that she's dealing
with not sure not sure you know there it
is
foreign
in summary let's see
she's going to keep creating content and
now that her husband is out of the
picture this is
quite sad to hear her say about it it is
good
yes I think I'm gonna take it easy
this is a
interesting time cleavage is this not
the right time no it is right here it is
right there
she said I'm excited to not work
cleavage anymore oh I can't I can't hear
oh Harry Potter uh fandom anyway she
goes on to say that she's excited to
um get eight hours of sleep
yeah it's really sad she's excited to
actually be able to see her horse she's
excited to watch TV again
she's excited to make content about
animals she's excited where she doesn't
have to
have her cleavage out all the time she
doesn't have to wear revealing clothing
she can go do social events she feels
like she has friends again she can
travel camping this is nuts
yeah just like writing down a list of
everything when she was talking about
the simplest things that you would
assume like I'm excited to sleep like
you don't realize
how horrible some people's situations
are
yeah and you know the
what a monster man holy [ __ ]
you know it's just so set marriage is
such a um
it is sacred I think to a degree I mean
your significant other should be your
your Ally and supporter and all of it
and when they turn into like your
biggest enemy
that's just a really bad bad [ __ ] up
situation you know it sucks
Beyond sucks
but she's okay
and uh we just wish her well all of
football Troopers and H Street Community
says yes
to amaranth Sam you're a amaranth fan
how's this whole thing been for you
it's extremely sad and I just hope that
she's safe and okay
so there it is
Sam has spoken
she said what we've all been thinking
that's good I'm happy that there's you
know a relatively good conclusion here I
mean the best possible conclusion really
I was afraid I was afraid he was going
to hurt her when she disappeared
yeah hearing the way he was talking to
her all right who knows who knows what
was happening
um up next let's see we've got James
Corden this actually is such a funny
story
I could need to pee though so I'm gonna
do that I'm gonna go pee and then we'll
do this James Corden all right story
sounds good
all right see ya peace
I made a little fun little Photoshop and
some down time but there wasn't a
placement for it earlier so would you
like to send it I'm gonna drop it right
now let's go send that Over You
Beautiful Swan cam
there he is there's Lou Louie the goat
this guy [ __ ] dude this dude [ __ ] hard
bro that guy thank you Cameron thank you
no thank you thank you you're the goat
being you
so should we all just create alter egos
for ourselves can we do that yeah I'm
down what's your name Lena what's your I
don't know I have to think of it it has
to be good true you have one don't you
Olivia oh my god do I I think you you
said something when Jack brought up the
whole thing oh no I think maybe you just
said Beyonce
oh Beyonce is Sasha Fierce
I'm trying to think
I would like an alter ego
yeah
Olive brush Olive fresh I don't know
whenever I would drink I would all my
name would always be like Victoria or
Veronica that's just what I it's like
your Doctor Jacqueline Mr Hyde type yeah
you have a little bit of Veronica energy
thank you for saying that yeah
you know that like kind of makes sense
somehow drunk me as Veronica for sure
fascinating
huh
mine's Al You Can Call Me Al
yeah you call me l
with Al like
call me
um
say that one more time yeah
father of potatoes oh you do eat raw
potatoes is that where that comes from
oh and you know and here's a little
lesson for you guys in Arabic usually
when you're referring to a gentleman
who's a father he would be Abu and then
whatever his first son's name is so your
father would be abudan right yeah just
saying what's Abba Abu means father of
well Abba oh
Hebrew there was a there was a gentleman
that was interviewed on the news once I
forget what it was for but he told the
news station his name was Abu Sharma
which means father of [ __ ]
and they rolled it the same as me oh
yeah check it out
shout out we'll do a PowerPoint on that
next week
I won't look at anything yes I'll be
totally surprised save the surprise
uh did we read this one from Noah Noah
Chavez
uh what do we have to do to make Ethan's
glorious hairstyle Trend like when the
mullet made its unfortunate return I see
some true potential here guys
he needs to get that [ __ ] on Tick Tock
that'll do it
oh
great Point Kim Lena were you talking
about that I said my mom calls me Lou
I remember that it wasn't that
specifically but I'll keep thinking that
is interesting though your middle name
oh my middle name is embarrassing let's
hear it I just saw Mine mine's Al minus
C
just C just C
s e a I think no I think Lena could top
you go ahead you want to tell yours
Selena mine is Ahmed what's wrong with
that I love that what's wrong with that
what's wrong with that Amy yeah
she's the only mind the Arabs they name
their daughters and their sons
middle name oh that's like my middle
name C stands for my Grandpa Charlie and
my sister Jay for the other Grandpa
Charlie M
wait your sister's middle name is Jay
for walking what they're like Men In
Black this is a little Boomer of me but
there was a whole joke on The Simpsons
back in the day that Homer's name was
Homer J Simpson but he didn't know what
the middle name was and there was a
whole episode dedicated to him trying to
figure out and he finally finds out it's
j j a y ah it's like from now on I'll be
known as Homer J Simpson should I be
Olivia s-e-e
right yeah exactly I think that's I
think he should I have a new Lena we
just figured it out it's C but with your
eyes and that's my name
that's cute you can go with that this is
good this is I missed this this is the
goat that's the goat he's the goat there
it is Zach now this makes sense
right because he's the go lose the gun
yes
what's your Alter Ego Ethan
who would be your alter ego name
oh I'm the goat
oh you're just the goat you're just goat
I don't know I'm just kidding I don't
know my Alter Ego [ __ ] I don't know you
have a quick answer to that
everyone else did I didn't have you have
a quick answer to your Alter Ego yeah
I'm out call me
great Baseline absolutely all right
let's talk about James Corden
trade warning apparently trigger warning
James Corden
apparently everybody hates this guy and
I'm just learning about this I didn't
know now obviously I'm not a fan of his
comedy I don't find him funny I don't
like the show I don't like I never even
like the karaoke [ __ ] because
it's just corny I mean I don't know it's
just like whatever but people loved it
and I didn't have a problem with his
personality I didn't know anything about
him but apparently he's the biggest
[ __ ] in the world
uh he has a track record
so much so that
um
kind of there's a lot of stories about
him I was you know reading about a
little bit for research he's leaving the
show
and the comments I saw online are just
viciously brutal man like everybody
hates this guy yeah
it's kind of feel bad everyone's like
stay in America we don't want you back
in UK it's [ __ ] gnarly how how
despised he is
what is it did you guys know about uh
James Corden I knew he had a reputation
for being a douche and yeah I I had
always heard that um
that he was really not liked in
the UK it's like where he's from for
some reason the pops did him dirty with
this one boy
yeah
James Corden ditches the diet as he
scoffs Pizza down after losing a stone
the bridge press was so bad he scoffs
Pizza down big fat loser James Corden
scoffing pizza I've had over 40 pizzas
in the last 30 days dude that's so wild
um
yeah and then he had this this was
something I learned about he tried to do
an AMA on Reddit
to promote
he says I'm James Corden along with Ben
Winston and five of our team members who
help us make carpool karaoke
ask me anything this was this huge
segment put him on the map this is from
three years ago and this went so
sideways
I don't know why any celebrity tries to
do these amas I mean I guess they don't
always end in disaster but there's so
many iconic disastrous ones at this
point the thing is if you're gonna do
this you got to be real about it you
gotta like actually be in there and
answering questions a lot of this [ __ ]
is just PR like they'll for sure here
like they leave one stupid response and
they don't know how dumb they look when
they do that right
um and all the comments in this thread
were just about what a piece of [ __ ] he
is I mean this is the top comment
hey James you won't remember me but me
and my friend sat at a table next to you
and Harry Styles plus some in the uh
Manchurian Legends in London's Chinatown
about six years ago we didn't bother you
but you are a massively entitled c word
see you next Tuesday who yelled and
treated the White staff like [ __ ] and
when one of my part party politely
suggested you calm down you got really
aggressive and threatened in a chubby
way like a boozy panda
laughs
so my question is this why did Harry
seem so cool while you were such a
massive throbbing bell end
you know that was written by an English
person yeah
um they're all like this
James I haven't the faintest idea of who
you really are but Reddit assures me
you're an [ __ ]
so as a professional [ __ ] are bidets
worth it or is that some weird
advertising craze going on where people
talk about spraying their [ __ ] with
water
my concern is that you know it'll be
spraying cold water on my balls and that
would suck
um
did he ever actually end up answering
any of these questions I'm sure not
these questions I'm sure he answered
some questions down below but that's the
thing about the way Reddit works is the
the upvoted comments rise and of course
all these juicy ones are the ones that
got to the top so you probably have to
dig to even find his replies
this the third comment is hey James is
this story true uh let's see
half an hour into a New York to London
flight passengers and business class
noticed women with a crying baby being
brought through the curtains by flight
attendant they looked on in Wild [ __ ]
as they saw the attendant director into
an empty seat next to James Corden
that can't be true can it expect funny
expecting a huge celebrity his fit to
kick off Gordon's cabin mates were
impressed to see that he didn't say a
word or make any sort of complaint he
simply put on a pair of noise canceling
headphones Holden eye mask over his eyes
and turned from her in her sleep pretty
decent of him right when the plane
landed though passengers were surprised
c chord and remained seated as the one
with the baby struggled to open the
overhauled locker and even more
surprised when she turned according and
said for [ __ ] sake can you at least
hold the baby while I get the bags down
the woman was his wife the baby was his
baby
wow Bravo
Bravo
wow
God that was really
that was something man they says um is
it true and follow-up did you hold the
baby in the end or did you expect your
wife to do everything
probably
that is that's a lot but God can you
imagine being hated by everyone I mean
people hate me but like
some people like me I guess before all
this stuff came out people would always
clown on him because he's always cast in
movie musicals and everyone's like
you're not good enough to be cast in
these like stop saying yes to these
projects like you're just famous and
that's why you're in it and I always
felt so badly for him because it was
like they never offered your dream you
would yeah of course and I always felt
that way and now that all of this is
coming out he is horrible in movie
musicals and we know well the cat was
honestly it was so bad it's like that
was so bad him in prom was so bad he
hosted the Tonys which Loki like it was
fine but people there was an outrage oh
my God I saw a clip yesterday that blew
my tits off oh my God that is just
horrific
looks great yeah look up uh here pull up
a clip of um James Corden arguing with
Sir Patrick
oh yes what's his name yes Captain
Captain Patrick Stewart Pat yeah yeah
yeah it's so hell no he didn't come from
my boy dude it's so uncomfortable
[ __ ] no during an award ceremony they
start arguing with each other it's
unbelievable
it wasn't schtick no no no you'll see it
is not stick bro here it is check this
[ __ ] out man
James Corden and Patrick Stewart Clash
at awards okay yo by the way I don't
care if Patrick Stewart's out of line
that [ __ ] is a knight that is
captive of cars the captain of the USS
Enterprise he is Professor X yes you put
respect on that motherfucker's name
that's right
yeah that was well hold on Patrick what
does that mean
all right I gotta stop you there uh Sir
Patrick did the pimples come from
Hershey's
it's an old timey joke
[Music]
hey come here fatty
what happened you eat the [ __ ] you eat
the kitchen hey come on
pickles come from Hershey's
hahaha
hold it hey are you a fan of Jonas
Brothers then hide your belly
whatever that means
yo you guys down with this or what it
looks kind of dope I'm kind of feeling
it now yeah you know it's kind of
everything to me right now it doesn't
look bad
from the side when I can't see the giant
valley in the middle you look at me like
this the back it's hard to take you
seriously the back is legitimate too the
profile is like kind of like the curly
mohawk bedazzle
the valley that exists oh brother
all right let's continue this is great
love me Patrick they love my belly oh
that's brutal they love me so much they
take pictures of me scarfing down Pizza
on the
put me in the tabloids
from one fact I do another
yeah
very uncomfortable
they both look like [ __ ]
okay somehow it's tilting uh I agree
like yeah he looks a lot worse in my
opinion but can I be honest
he's the host he got to keep it classy
you can't start fighting
people like that I mean that was just
wild holy [ __ ] balls dude
damn
yo Philip DeFranco be talking about
Markiplier I just want to know when we
see his dick
yo Markiplier show me your [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
are you talking all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's a tasteful nude anyway when your
dick's just out of the zipper
and you're in a tuxedo and just your
dicks out of the zipper
is that a tasteful nude printing [ __ ]
he's wearing a tux these are all gonna
do tasteful nude on orange pants he's
wearing a tuxedo and only his dick is
out of the zipper is that what you mean
Mark you freak
his dick and balls are out oh that see I
was on the fence I feel like the ball's
out is that's not tasteful
opportunity calls are interesting
yeah whatever mark
that is your real name
anyway
uh so about James Corden I'm actually I
opened the Reddit account where they
posted the AMA
so here's the comments yeah they're all
downloaded
um but I'm trying to see
so far nobody
James hasn't responded it all says
the other staff's name like here it says
Lauren okay I think the ones that don't
say that are probably him like so that
those right there oh okay so he did
respond yeah so Paul McCartney was my
most exciting person I've worked with he
was so sweet to all the fans
yeah if you scroll down there were some
that didn't have a signature no list of
banned songs that's it it's just he's
answering the mundane [ __ ] about carpool
karaoke you know what I mean
uh Diana Miller's book our Corporal
Karaoke gets to popular seven so I don't
think she has a problem with booking
thanks we all love Sir Paul McCartney
yeah
no near accidents we always drive very
slowly that's what I'm saying you can't
come here and give answers like that
you're just gonna look like a [ __ ]
yeah and this is the Public's Fault by
the way if you're gonna be putting them
on Reddit you got to know better you
gotta
get them involved and that's what I
meant I mean how many years ago was this
this was three years ago yeah
yeah I mean I this was long after the
infamous like Woody Harrelson one like
it it's
gotta be like a known thing among
publicist that it's risky to do one of
these it's their job it's literally
their job yeah I it's not my job and I
know that right
she should be whoever set this up should
be fired
they probably were yeah I had to guess
he didn't answer oh here's another one
he answered apologies didn't mean to
sound rude ah what did he say wait I
need the full comment
even sounds rude in the comments
I did full comment yeah that just brings
you the comment section you have to
click context yeah there's another
button that says context right to the
left of full comment okay context yep
with games ever make another carpool
karaoke with uh Gordon Ramsay oh [ __ ]
it's all been blocked
he said apologies didn't mean to sound
rude this is Ryan oh [ __ ] get out of
here Ryan
anyway so that's a little background
James
so the story developing is that he was
recently banned
from a New York City restaurant when the
owner of the restaurant called him out
on Instagram real quick before you jump
into it we just got a super chat for
five British Pounds Sterling I served
James Corden once at my old job and all
the claims of him being rude are 100
True dude how can you be so insufferable
of a dick that everybody that runs into
has a bad experience holy [ __ ]
uh Matt asked just got off work what is
Ethan's hair he looks like a prison
[ __ ] with peace and love
that's what I am that's what I've always
been bro nothing more nothing less
so Keith McNally the owner of a
restaurant in New York called uh
Balthazar which I guess is a big deal
there
posted on Instagram absolutely
bombing on him bro
this post went viral has 41 000 likes
this horrific picture where did what is
this Boomer [ __ ] you took a that's a
photo of a screen if I've ever seen one
one pixel
it is so funny
that's like my mom's Style
yeah so this is all legit like you
always hear stories you hear rumors here
is the owner of a restaurant a famous
restaurant by a famous restaurant here
who has banned him listen to this [ __ ]
James Corden is a hugely gifted comedian
and a tiny cretan of a man
the most abusive customer to my
Balthazar server since the restaurant
opened 25 years ago I don't often 86 a
customer but today I 86th Cordon it did
not make me laugh here are two examples
of the funny man's treatment of my staff
in June James Corden was here on table
61 although this is diabolical it
happens very occasionally in all
restaurants I didn't understand what he
meant by that 61 or is that just about
61 is supposed to be like the bad table
at a restaurant really that's what
someone said in the Twitter reply to
this when they said what does that mean
so I guess he got [ __ ] he got put at a
shitty table
after eating his main course Gordon
showed the hair
to Bell balthazar's manager G who was
very apologetic
Gordon was extremely nasty to G and said
get us another round of drinks this
second and also take care of all of our
drinks so far this way I write any nasty
review on Yelp or anything like that I
guess you meant this way I won't write
any nasty review
bro I mean look we've all had hairs in
our food but
bro how can you be such a douche like
I'm I'm checking and saying that uh
that's the most desired table in the
restaurant some of the most desired 61.
so he was hooked up yeah
so what do you mean yeah that although
this is diabolical it happens very
occasionally in all restaurants oh like
maybe we gave them great treatment so he
is very diabolical and it happens I
guess in all restaurants
okay we'll have to just um use our
imagination on that one there uh Mr
restaurant here
um manager report number two James
Corden was at a restaurant with his wife
on October 9th for brunch he asked for a
table outside
brunch maitre d Ali Walkers took the
party to table 301. Mr accordion's wife
ordered an egg yolk omelette
with gruyere cheese and salad by the way
I never heard of an egg yolk omelet have
you usually I hear egg white they was
like [ __ ] the whites I don't want any
whites all yo what is that like is that
good
I've never heard that egg yolk
it's kind of wild bro
as it turns out table 61 at Balthazar
doesn't carry any special meaning other
than being one of the most desired seats
in the House 60 61 and 62 are big red
booths at the back of the restaurant so
I guess this restaurant's a big deal
right there's a mirror above 61 that
gives occupants a panorama of the entire
restaurant
um so he was hooked up so he's
diabolical
yeah for being a he got the best seat
anything a moody [ __ ]
Gooch he's being a giant gooch
um
anyway moving on his wife ordered an I'm
sorry I'm just so confused I'm so
interested egg yolk omelette
I want to see what what does this look
like eh
probably just like yellow yep I was
right
called it
[ __ ] called it dude
bro I love that they're like I want the
just the I want the whites no just the
yolk
so his wife ordered an egg yolk omelette
a few minutes after they received the
food James called their server and told
her there was a little bit of egg white
mixed with the egg yolk
that is such a weird complaint that is
so [ __ ] bizarre
like I get if it's white and it has
yellow and maybe you're on a strict low
cholesterol diet
but it's like you got some healthy [ __ ]
in my [ __ ] nasty [ __ ]
I'm seeing this online a little bit too
and I'm seeing in the chats um sometimes
61 means there could be hair or food uh
hair in your food when you order oh okay
okay
bro you got to explain this better we're
we're grasping at straws would he put
that I think
it was a good it was a good uh table
based on
the the news yeah it definitely was a
good table because I saw another time
article about it so it is a good table
for sure but 61 will could you could you
even tell if there was a bit of egg
white in your egg yolk omelette
uh you must can unless there was just
like one little streak of white that
they didn't mix it at all
uh so they explained that there's a
little bit of white they informed the
floor manager the kitchen remade the
dish but unfortunately it was sent with
home fries instead of a salad
[Laughter]
that's when James Corden began yelling
like crazy to servers you can't do your
job
you can't do your job maybe I should go
and maybe I should go into the kitchen
and cook The Omelette myself
bro you cannot be serious
the server was very apologetic and
brought him over uh brought G over to
the table he returned the dish and after
that everything was fine he gave them
promo champagne glasses to smooth things
out G said Cordon was pleasant to him
but nasty to the server MK the server
was very shaken but professional that
she has continued to finish her shift
oh my God diabolical I'm so sorry it
refers to the hair and food not the 61
yes it's like [ __ ] solving the uh
what is it called yes yes we got it so
wait
61 is a table diabolical is supposedly
code for the hair
it's like the [ __ ] Da Vinci Code
although this is diabolical but he
didn't even mention the hair yet
no he's saying diabolical I don't know
he didn't even mention the air though it
doesn't make any sense what's the
confusion I stepped away wow
it's fine we don't need to go on about
this okay but anyway
um
this is stuff you hear like happens like
this isn't real people Behavior
yeah I um
I worked I've talked about this on the
show before but I worked as a waiter for
many years at a California Pizza Kitchen
in the valley here in Los Angeles and
the location that we were at um happened
to be in a very affluent neighborhood so
we had a lot of celebrity uh uh guests
come in and you know the vast majority
of them were always really Pleasant I
only had a a couple incidents with
famous people that were pulling this
kind of stuff and um did it like this
bad though
um
yeah really yeah do you remember any the
one that always stands out to me one of
the biggest [ __ ] pricks who used to
come in on a regular basis and it was
always like nobody ever wanted to serve
him and his family because it was just
always a [ __ ] thing with Scott Baio
he's got both yep go ahead and drop the
T no no no he's an actor and uh wait let
me pull up a photo of this mother you'll
recognize him Scott Beowulf Scott
Beowulf that's right and so what was so
bad about him it's just there was always
there was always something and and you
know I I remember dude
this [ __ ] was a heartthrob
should I need to go back in time and
live then
and some charger baby and you know what
uh because this was long before this era
but he turned out to be a Big Mac ahead
I believe surprise surprise yeah well do
you remember any specific incidents
I mean not really I just remember he was
known to the staff because again he was
somewhat of irregular he would come in
once every couple of weeks or something
no
not at all and there was always a
problem with their food they would send
it back all the time you know being
really [ __ ] rude to the servers and
yeah he was just he was a prick [ __ ]
that guy
how about that huh God bail ladies and
gentlemen yep certified [ __ ] dude
once when I was a waiter a lady a
customer asked me if I was she goes she
points at her head she goes are you like
are you like here that's what she said
she pointed at her head like am I [ __ ]
in the head really how bad was your
service bro I literally just walked up
and right behind her one of my
co-workers like spilled like hot tea and
like was screaming and like the whole
restaurant was like gasping and looking
over I was looking over and that's when
somehow this lady didn't notice and so
as I was looking over she asked me that
good time yeah you know I I worked in a
restaurant for a long time I never
really had any really insane things that
I can remember
I mean the the worst thing I remember is
something I did which was spill a glass
of wine on a kid's head
our beer actually was a full glass of
beer oh man
don't get mad yeah they were pissed I
mean obviously though they weren't like
they weren't dicks about it but they
were super mad they were drank beer they
were honestly gracious enough right and
the best part that I can't even feel bad
about now but it is what it is
they were a party over six you know what
I mean Dan
of course I know oh yeah
so they tipped my ass and I'm a [ __ ]
choice
I love that auto gratuity baby it was
eight for us at our restaurant though
yeah it might have been eight I don't
remember but what happened is I had a
big old tray of beer we had a tap and it
was you know I was serving the beers and
just like a [ __ ] idiot loser it's SP
the bear fell over right over this their
son's head and all over them
he was crying oh no uh they were pissed
obviously there's nothing you can do I
mean you bring them a towel I brought
him some glasses of wine did the baby
get drunk
I don't I don't know wasted
yeah but it was awkward obviously but I
was like
well good thing this Auto gratuities on
here these [ __ ] in my ass
yeah Scott Baio really stood out to me
because the vast majority of like the
famous people that would come in they
were always really sweet
even celebrities that I'm not
necessarily that fond of which always
kind of made me feel bad well like we
had the Kardashians come in uh some of
the sisters on a regular basis and uh
they were always really polite and
always tipped well shout out to the
Kardashians if you're famous and you're
a dick and and yeah you have to be such
a [ __ ] Maniac because you know that
if you [ __ ] around people are gonna talk
about it for sure so to still have the
hutzpah to do that means you are really
[ __ ] up indeed so homie posted an
update the restaurant here took another
uh photo of a YouTube video
like his last one
this one was this one and then here oops
I just sent somebody Super Chat back in
the chat I'm gonna just send it to you
Dave Grohl oh what's up Dave Grohl oh no
Dave gross do you have girls here they
have girls here Dave Grohl said he was
an [ __ ] during carpool karaoke he
said he'd never go back really
apparently I actually saw somebody say
that earlier too is that in a video or
just in an interview because there's
that video I'd love to see it Dave Grohl
was another one that used to come into a
restaurant but he was super [ __ ] yeah
I'm sure yeah he was awesome goat
I saw Dave Grohl at uh in Woodland Hills
when we lived there the mall that was
that was where my restaurant it was
around there so was it that outdoor mall
there uh the Topanga Mall yeah yeah
there used to be yeah that's where I saw
him in his family walk I worked at that
one and the one over in Encino and both
of those areas have quite a few he lives
in Encino why would he live in Encino
he's got a it's a nice ass area [ __ ] a
lot of celebrities are there I would
just think if you're like super rich you
would live the Encino one was where the
Kardashians used to come in too because
I think that well now that they're in
Calabasas but I think at the time they
were ins you know I don't know if I was
as rich as him I would choose to live
like in a in West L.A where it's not a
thousand degrees every day he's got a
[ __ ] in like a state he bought and he
like converted the Backlot into like a
studio like it's a dope [ __ ] house
yeah there's there are some insane
properties in Encino and until I I don't
think this is true anymore unfortunately
but for a long time the valley was much
you could get a much nicer place in the
valley than West LA it's still cheaper
it's still still cheaper yeah a lot I
mean it's just all super expensive now
yeah
damn look at that part bro I can't stop
you have not been able to stop touching
your hair how far is that right it's
just been
a constant it's like a bowl cut fire bro
so Dave Grohl said this in a article
interview yeah read the quote
uh let's see made him a little
uncomfortable
trying to find the actual the whole
thing but that's what he said I'm sure
he was a little bit more polite than
saying he's an ass but you can read
between the lines kind of thing it was
clear also during their carpool karaoke
that he was having a bad time because
Jews yeah uh Dave Grohl would be like
just sing the [ __ ] song man and
um and apparently like quoted in that
video he says his face makes it worse I
don't want people to actually think that
the song sounds like that
anyway here's the update from the
restaurant here Keith McNally James
Corden just called me and apologized
profusely having [ __ ] up myself more
than most people I strongly believe in
second chances so if James Corden lets
me host his Late Late Show for nine
months I'll immediately rescind his ban
no of course not but anyone magnanimous
enough to apologize to a deadbeat layout
like me and my staff doesn't deserve to
be banned from anywhere especially
Balthazar so come back to the five and
dime Jimmy Corden Jimmy Corden All is
Forgiven what a guy
hold it still drag disaster publicly
sounds like Jimmy Lee's nice with Jimmy
Corden
Jenny would never Jimmy wouldn't have
where's your papers
he's yeah he's definitely done that yeah
he doesn't insult the uh serversed the
bus boys the uh
yeah the kitchen staff can I get extra
ice no no no not that ice that border
agent we gotta Deport you oh hey yo it's
an old-timey joke
Cameron take your glasses off you're
making a spectacle of yourself
he's not even wearing glasses that's
what you mean that's a championship
that would be a right on point for Jimmy
hey what's up you fat cow lose some
weight you're embarrassing yourself oh
you suck everyone hates you
die alone [ __ ]
jokes I'm gonna get a million text
messages from him now what do you say
about me on the show guys I I've been
getting a lot of um still
I think I got banned yeah I got this oh
my April Behavior it's [ __ ]
incredible every like 100 of the time
oh it said no no this time we got banned
for adult nudity and sexual activity
it's literally just a shocked
it's too damn hot
so funny man you know the naked Dome you
know what I thought of and I would love
to see is a carpool karaoke with Jimmy
Lee with two of them in a car together
dude the first segment I ever suggested
when I got hired was a carpool karaoke
with you guys and then I found out
Zach's longtime dream has been uh car
what is it karaoke with the clients
wait who would I do but you have to be a
good singer to do that don't you have to
be a carpool karaoke I think James
Gordon did it he you and Trisha did it
we literally did that on the show he
could hit the notes but like Dave
Grohl's thing was like you don't sound
good singing my songs
he literally said this is the last one
and girl said promise oh my God is Dave
being a dick I don't know that sounds
kind of dickish no Gordon was being
pretty obnoxious I mean he has a track
record Dave girl's like the nicest guy
that's what I hear yeah
we blame James
we love you Dave
shut up Dave
uh let's see well basically there's a
few other stories here but I mean
it's got to be about three hours right
Dan we're at 2 40. so yeah we could wrap
it up 2 40 huh 240. we could do a little
longer then it's a short episode for us
because nobody doesn't like us nobody
Buck goes live for two hours 40 minutes
on a podcast and says that's a short
episode nobody but a five times a week
and I'm not on that top list
we need to get on the top list like for
real what the one the audio one
like the Spotify one is that what you're
talking about how to find the apple one
apple yeah that's my top five
is
is Drake Drake Drake Drake
I was like just converting you know I
was being tongue-in-cheek with it I
don't know I know but it's just it
it would have bothered me like right or
like an OCD kind of thing if I don't
hear the second part of that song it's
like their chord resolving yeah exactly
exactly that I don't know how we can get
on those top lists because I don't even
[ __ ] a song ate that onion bro but
son texted me did Dan quit yo
he's the first non-boomer
that's kind of well a lot of our
audience believed it too I mean I don't
know it's not I think he currently just
cares did we do a poll to see who
believed it and who didn't
in chat I don't think we did would you
like to do that I'm curious would that
be a good poll
that would be a good pull would that be
a good pull would that be a good poll I
didn't hear the question I believe it do
you want to pull the audience to see if
they ate the onion on the quitting thing
what percentage of the audience believe
this like yeah we can do the pull but
it's like he thinks it's about people
that just see the title and then I don't
know it's it's funnier who cares what
you believe I'll tell I'll tell his son
yes and then let's see if no no no no we
can be here tomorrow morning he's gonna
be like all right I quit too then yeah
pull out
did you believe Dan really quit
shut the [ __ ] up cam
sorry
love you Dan I know you're too you're
too sweet I feel bad yeah I'm not sweet
yeah you're a sweetheart my I found out
my Alter Ego you guys can call me
switchblade
that's so [ __ ] cool oh man that's my
Loop [ __ ]
dude we were excited as [ __ ] do we ever
explain if they shut the [ __ ] up cam
meme I don't know if we to the audience
but like the food I think we mentioned
it before but yeah cam Kim's always very
timid when he's seeing if he can get any
food when we're ordering food and so
well that was before I had a mic and and
I was hungry yeah I know let's do the
poll did you believe Dan uh was really
quitting
yes
or no
switchblade I love switchblade thanks
for calling you that some people call it
a switchblade
did you believe Dan was really quitting
and the oh see 70 said no okay okay a
bunch of Wise Guys here huh yeah they're
on to us
well let's see how many people care how
many views this gets depends it will
prove how much people care uh-oh ha got
him if Dan did quit the mole people
would invade the surface says Rory oh
that's our mole man thanks for the donut
Rory Rory's always hitting us with fat
donations about the mole people he's
very insistent about it thank you Rory
all right guys I'm gonna call it a day
we'll be here tomorrow morning for
another great episode of leftovers
um
that's it we got we got a great show
tomorrow and on Friday so uh stay tuned
do you want to um
we kind of know what we're talking about
tomorrow do you want to tease it at all
what are we talking about tomorrow we're
doing we're doing a midterm elections
like rundown special
people are saying Hassan is mad what do
you mean
I'm watching is live right now but he's
mad he's responding to your text
what cause his ass ate the onion well
did you just tell him that it's true no
I said it's no I said okay
he said
I literally just said
little Notch just a goof he said Jesus
Christ that was so sad oh well that's
nice
shout out son love you man
literally
Dan loves you for that
so funny
all right guys see you tomorrow for
leftovers yeah we're gonna do um the
midterms are coming up so we're gonna do
a big midterm super show uh and
we're gonna get real political on you
uh and also but have a laugh at the same
time you know what I mean
we
right
right
oh next week on leftovers we have a
channel five Andrew Callahan
next week though not tomorrow I want to
ask him you know he's got a lot coming
up a lot going on
uh
[ __ ] my head dude I gotta stop touching
it
it's been you have not stopped for
almost three hours [ __ ] yeah my head is
don't talk too much my head is getting
um like tender for me
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
morning we love ya have a great week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]